[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right seventeen live what's going on
original next level gaming my man Stanga
he says another Sunday another
award-winning I lost podcast coming with
a great guest yes Giuseppe has arrived
they all he is here with me and allowed
to somebody we could say hello to the
people so they can hear you real quick
hello everyone
the area is see the legend the less very
smooth very smooth so yeah man we just
waiting for addict - hi cool thank you I
might wear for a dick King will arrive
soon I'm gonna mute when King because he
always comes in with music and we're not
trying to get copyright strike so we
would not do that solve is always smooth
late yeah a cat daddy man I see that
Boston the prophecy is real nice it's a
great dungeon hi Joe we will see y'all
in a bit just want to do a little quick
my check and then we get the group in
we're always waiting for anak citizeness
yeah sleep it was good it was good
alright fellas see it a bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright hey we are laughs welcome to the
Isle or podcast and the Lords of gaming
dotnet episode number 166 and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got gears tactics and
Splash Damage
Sony invested in Epic Games and Xbox
interested in WB games to discuss so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a lord who is not only one of
the top coders in the games industry
with his extensive programming
background has one of the most
impressive and diverse resumes to prove
it
introducing the principal gameplay
programmer at Splash Damage and
developer of the iconic Gears tactics
franchise a fellow passionate lord of
retro gaming and the most fluent
speaking Italian on Twitter laughs from
the UK by way of Italy and making his
debut into the realm of the Lords mahmud
Lord Giuseppe now Maria how you doing
sir I like that pronunciation
pronunciation would never come out of my
mouth it would sound it was it would
butcher the name so bad I would have to
just literally go out the van I can
barely pronounce most English stuff
there's no first when you are lord of
your room the lord of coding and
programming man first well how you been
doing about even I've been holding up
with everything
oh it's and I didn't great actually
yeah there's a lot going on and I'm yeah
I'm super happy to be here nice nice
good to have you get to have you down
home real quick what have you been
playing have you got a chance to play
any games lately
oh well right now I'm actually replaying
persona 5 yeah and then I'm in a sort of
retro gaming okay what we doing so well
at the moment I'm flip-flopping between
Adam
it's roguelikes yes so Tom and ADA
Marmite go to rob lights ok and and then
some other stuff so recently I'm I'm
fixing on MSX computer okay I have here
so I'm I've been playing MSX games I saw
the the the Sega stuff today little a
little pain injury yeah II brought you
got like a throw of retro Italian
commercial for saying it I was I was
yeah that was part of my childhood
Yoshi actually I grew up with a PC I but
III let's say that Sega and the Mega
Drive
that's how yes it's called year had a
big impact on me not even in my I played
it only air with some friends I was or
in a weird way it was so it was also
what got me strangely enough into
programming as well there is a link
between also we gotta make a connection
with your career or we know I mean it's
it's just how it all started it's um
so I obviously and it's um so yeah I
started programming when I was a
teenager so so I was I think 12 or
something and I was dabbling with
different you know game making software
and stuff like that but the breakthrough
moment where it was when I got my hands
into in on a 56k
let's go Internet let you hold that
thought you said because I know cuz we
go to get we gonna dive deep ditch I
just got we got I got to get the Lord's
it we could go right back to you as
we've got a lot to talk it you out here
about to get it to your bag and I love
it so you already know we've got the
Four Horsemen of gaming those are
original Lords of the rub here at the
round table oh oh my co-host the Como's
with the empty chair that is not there
or the most of the Conqueror who is not
there Lord of reviews and how of the
young wolf who is still not there had
muted Lord addict will get him on to
come back that's he left right what I'm
doing this intro awesome salute the
attic and of course we still have almost
technical game enjoyed the solo gamer
who lives with a single player selfish
experience and also disaster Davis
mister off la profile Illuminati and
lore patron of the iron baked mommy
Lord saw what are you doing sir I'm
doing good you don't do good what's up
it's perfect for Atticus he would just
come back just in time to interrupt
would you would you like to defer you
know I know I'll let him go first cuz I
I need to get into a little bit of a
talks okay I did your intro without you
present but on that issue I'm sorry
about that like the Facebook guys like
this glitch now or if you don't if your
Facebook's up and someone calls you you
I can denied I denied it on my phone but
am i living here in my laptop had my
Facebook up and it just kept ringing oh
I'm done going in there not shutting it
off we said the Attic was putting of the
tattoo video on kings
I can neither confirm or deny that I've
been only fans for IOP now shout out to
LA so we cheat final super chest so kid
combat talk with some MMA possibly since
corrupted cog is deflecting ever be wow
I understand I saw the tweet yesterday
that you put out and I'll explain why I
am not qualified today to even talk
about that but our sovereign sastra damn
I think I took Sasha sobs name you know
he's no longer why what did you predict
everything I predicted a lot of things
and I'll get it today oh yeah my intro
Brown we get so addict what's going on
not much ran sir actually I feel very
well rested I don't know how that
happened I definitely I definitely
didn't get a whole lot of sleep maybe
I'm just running on pure adrenaline
that's why the creator of one of my
favorite games this year what are the
creators here and in that alone is
keeping me away we don't get that that
the strategy ko award is gonna be proud
of the audience I write it of we go
right yeah definitely that now keep in
mind we will just just to people know at
the beginning I've gotten countless
messages asking or overreacting to the
xbox show the answer to that is yes oh
my gosh yes yes a resounding yes no the
question is it's all gonna be of course
having will be coming down with
something that day I lost my foot a
dryer so that's the answer that because
I had like eight people ask me I'm like
we've been reacting to everything why
would we miss that oh I see we're now
reacting to the Ubisoft phone we didn't
react to EA we didn't react to you B so
we know
they mad at us that we didn't react to
the Avengers I was like look Matt after
seeing the ei thing I think everyone in
the chat could have used I mean we made
that boring tech thing they did on Saudi
look like I think we could have eaten us
I think that day we would have struck
out if we could make that let we make
anything with boy mark Cerny did ask for
people ears so that has been it's a
because I get I need to get it solved
chillin man I finally finished it on
Wednesday yeah I'm gonna spoil the cast
on on Monday on a dolphin Castle X
Channel no so we can really break down
the psychology of each character like I
thought we was going to do and get into
all listen you're available Monday and
9:00 p.m. you know I'll be in there so
you know I'll see it's done um I will
say this I started to listen to you guys
for the cast a little bit and just I
didn't finish it yet but I'll say this
um I think everything that they set out
to do for the most part landed for the
most part um I think this is a game that
only Naughty Dog can make I think this
is a game that only they are willing to
make right because of the narrative
twists and turns and and and the way
they decided to tell this story
now for me it falls just short of
masterpiece and it falls there for a
specific reason I won't say the details
but they're free there's a point where
you where you sort of think that the
game is over and it's and it's new and
it's not and the things that have
to propel the story forward from there
specifically something an attic
mentioned about character motivations
mm-hmm
it didn't make sense to me out of
curiosity obviously no spoiler you give
this a 10 out of 10 like Keene does no
no no no make no mistake I everyone
should play this game mm-hmm whether
you've given I love it you're gonna hate
it
in terms of you know this thing that
people have with the love for the
characters yeah you got to remember like
Neil druckmann
and the actors they love these
characters more than anybody right so
they had to make the decision to tell
this story in the way that they did
knowing full well how people would react
so you know all that aside I you have to
always remember this is their story to
tell you have no agency here or you're
not thank you
so I will say this but it almost broke
the game for me because all the
motivation really was you were you out
of for the Attucks world oh boy this is
manic world it's like I told you called
me you know like it stopped at the
became is bad cuz it's not it's doesn't
make sense in a lot of scenarios and I
don't even I think for the most part it
does I don't I don't know I say that a
lot of scenarios what is this one
singular propels that propels you
towards the climax towards a conclusion
right and the motivations in that moment
to take you now mind you for me I feel
the ending and everything is fantastic
okay I just felt cheated because I felt
like I didn't earn that God because of
what happened just prior to the I got
you to the point where I was like I had
to get up a minute I was upset like and
Wow
went down I was upset but at the end of
the day I mean I think much like the
characters in this game had to get over
it and and and I got over it I don't get
over anything Jessica just because I
have to agree with the domain I ain't
that's to solve from world to think
right there like it's either you gonna
like it or you don't is their story so
I'm gonna doing this one way in the
middle when I'm pointing my flag down
I'm from like I said it's not a
masterpiece for that reason I think that
it's sort of it just didn't land for me
the ending I felt was fantastic and
enough there's only one thing there
truly matters Wow whoa yeah that's
pretty much it I needed a little sort of
like cool down after that so I played I
picked up curse of the moon part 2 let's
thing yeah did you pick I got the switch
let's go
you know cross Cody's in-game path no no
I got that blood-stained isn't
specifically switch it gets a lot of
love so we just try to educate people
I'll of my cornea we'll talk about how
use regret and play Mortal Kombat on the
switch and I discuss this the ports of
bigger games are hitting miss are very
interesting technically but you know not
great play but the original games or the
indie games are absolutely and of course
we have the newly tattooed a credible
hook of it aka the access gamer the Lord
of combat sports king of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved Lord King how we do exerts
tripping out with tattoos yesterday
shout out to will me heard on the
seven-hour fetching Montana one if you
have still tree on my chest the nipple
area is definitely completely scared was
going on heard all the nipple came out
was like what's going on we have the
crest we have the the crest of the
Lord's now officially tattooed on your
chest is is it official how does it feel
how does it feel tender right now for
seven hours here we did take a break
it which is you know whatever I rather
do it you know just keep going but you
know somebody I came and get a tattoo
and the way we had scheduled did you
know the king messed up but um cut out
to full moon tattoo artist studios and
own in Montana for taking care that tab
given will be heard you know pitches
updates while I was going down because a
grandson with him yesterday so he you
know couldn't do the live faith but the
video will be up soon because I didn't
have I wasn't access to a couple of yeah
I got a edit you know a lot of that
stuff you're not gonna get seven hours
worth of video that's my shout out to
you for putting out the preview you say
to give us a little taste like you even
have to do that like I was love like you
definitely understand if you want to be
a member the room the new is not fans
only shout out Picasa we choose to
follow suit chat he said where's Kings
only fans leaked out the will be with
the $15 super jet who did that we didn't
get a chance to watch their me yesterday
because you know the king was I was just
tired
under the room yeah because I was in a
cool environment right so the it was
completely cool it felt Arctic to be
honest with you and then after I left
out of the tattoo shop now you in one
freezing cold situation and you walk
outside to humidity in New York City oh
yeah it felt like somebody put a
weighted vest on me and I was like oh my
god and it completely drained me of my
energy so I took the whole night to get
my energy back very good that's um so
it's about the game I got I gotta give
commanders props yo anchorman man told
you you know we love for a lot 76 and it
has you know I turned it up by tuning it
up and I got me I mean me a good head
look grain a big it was nice it was no
just for me because it's a
post-apocalyptic so you had it like that
but the game is definitely fallout is
all out yo and I was like the framerate
is beautiful everything because you know
I'm planning on X so it looks fantastic
but also somebody told me the download
cross co-star downloaded oh I hate horns
I was Jay Bailey don't the crest up
welcome to the room I'm a little early
you guys would get it but JP I just
heard horns new member the round salute
oh those crisp game is out of control
avatar yeah it's so many games inside
game past right now because I want to
get back to all the Kingdom Hearts and I
have all these stuff in my queue so I'm
trying to like do this round robin and
stuff but I have so I did so many
interviews this week leading up that was
why there was no ko Western but I got I
got a box coming in tomorrow so a box is
oh that's the box that you guys voted on
you guys put it on Miles Morales so you
already know that ahead of time that a
premium format will be here tomorrow I'm
doing spoiler cast on last of us to the
remix the more in depth deep dive up
like that psychology of the game the the
magnificent
he's gotta bring it down more to justify
the nonsense the girl Neil druckmann
oh my god be sure you little Druckman
emoji soon ya know there's so much
there's so much symbolism in that game
no that's crazy crazy stuff that like
you know you don't it can go right over
your head doesn't matter you you take
from the game what you want but like
even when it comes down like to the
music and like it's everything
everything is there's a lot
um no could you please tell me who won
what fights yesterday yeah we have a
couple yeah yeah I think I'm up to Dan
right I got shouted and Reggie sees it
gaming in a building find out super chat
I am hereby relinquishing my shares and
Kings left me giving the news this week
attic it's all yours
I'll watch from the bushes we got the
Rattler chocolate dollar super chat yeah
absolutely
I once again set out to Joe Bailey for
joining around again hold on as we see
the philosopher check also king Hulk is
on its way sir you might get Hulkbuster
Iron Man to go head-to-head with him no
so I don't know I'm in position because
tomorrow well Tuesday I have another
unboxing that we will be doing on Dolph
castle X channel and the head of spec
fiction a statue purchasing company you
know you could purchase your statues to
spec fiction I don't have payment plans
and stuff like that and he has a whole
transformation that he might you know
get the King for a night price so that's
that to two thousand dollars so I think
he was talking about that's what he's
gonna try to do oh okay got you guys
everybody remember was a joke I know
that's been pretty much a baby we gotta
move on a lot of show and of course we
have the gaming engine himself the
shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading that realness Andromeda IOP
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to the
last word let's ride a man salute he
boxes my bro we had chibi Kim from the
amazing resolute clan talking destiny
destiny a fantastic place seasonal
rivals is amazing solve and that's why
I'm glad because season I was a bit just
these good I don't play anything so hold
up my destiny brother right now
shoutout to
Gaming Forte Dubrow have great stream
Lords glad to be affiliated with great
people have an iced coffee on myself
slow mo and the rest of the brat podcast
wrapped in the building slow in the
building Forte the building salute you
already know it's all love but yeah man
it's been I've been doing that and let's
go say yeah just hit some great story
beats bear rockin that and then
hopefully I get everything done it looks
like I'm gonna ease right in to go sushi
sushi back this week so we'll win yeah
I've actually been playing that slay
that the spire that's on game paths
whoa let's go let's go see already no
solo we got allowed to show you
obviously we know why all right here Oba
saw what we're gonna do we're gonna
appease the masses and talk a little MMA
or so real quick I saw the last movie
something to drink yes because I know I
know they get mad possibly just photos
with you um I sorted three I sorted the
Aldo and Jana blear-eyed
oh I saw the entire card right okay oh
so from the jump um Amanda heba's versus
uh Paige Vanzant pages is outclassed
again I mean I think something about
Paige is like fight IQ like once once
she gets in there she sort of seems to
forget and lose what she's learned and
when she's put in certain situations she
just kind of loses it and she just got
out um in a white made a statement
saying like I think she should consider
free agency Wow yeah I think Paige I
mean maybe she needs to go someplace
else to feel like she the spotlight is
less on her mm-hmm and improve so yeah I
don't know what her future is in the UFC
on then we had the rematch between
Jessica and ROG yes and dog rolls yes
[ __ ] Rose pulled it out um it was a
great fight yet again and Raj was like a
relentless you know in in range one all
day and mom throwing bombs and Rose
managed to keep the distance she got hit
with a lot of stuff too but she managed
to use the jab keep their distance and
usual feet and in general there was a
shield ring generalship whatever it was
it was obviously sort of won the fight
but it was very well contested
and I would like to see I'm thinking
Rose is gonna fight I was genuinely oh
yes the title mom that be interested
Rose do what looks like she's
recommitted she'll ask her she's then we
had Pietra yarn vs. Jose Aldo I saw that
woman I met that boy may Aldo look like
he got shot with the [ __ ] out maker yes
so our old the thing about Aldo is man
al ghost he looks great for his age he
still has odd he still had the thing
about although is you can't teach an old
dog new tricks and Aldo is he's just not
built to be standing in the pocket with
people anymore like many wars like he's
not built for that with somebody who can
go toe-to-toe with him and he doesn't
really utilize his jiu-jitsu at all so
when he decides that's what he's gonna
do which is you know 99% of the time
he's probably gonna be on the receiving
end of L because it's just like the chin
isn't the same no matter what you'd say
we took some good shots here but it's
just not the same boy it was a good
fight though eh there was a couple of
hours Aldo did have some moments though
yeah oh absolutely awesome moments when
he just kicks the leg off the one thing
to let me spin yeah featherweight
championship rematch with Alexander
Vulcan Oski versus bless max Holloway
max got run again fantastic fight well
can testify all the way through Volga
now ski again using using the fact that
he has you know uh issues with with
height and and reach when it comes to
fighting Holloway he managed to move in
and out very well
he caught Holloway with a lot but I
think Holloway just kind of commanded
the ring for the most part of that fight
especially the first three rounds it was
sort of obvious so to say that he lost
that fight was how do you see that in
MMA and then of course we have the made
of zero face let's go Metiria tomorrow
who's been vs. Jorge Masvidal game bred
daybreak
and honestly Guzman did what he needed
to do to win
soundboards ow yeah the boring
we will not pleased at all and Kumar
told them in the beginning Masood all
he's managed to get his cannot pose
awful what not but the thing is he was
just not ready for wrong once you so he
could take him down yeah it was a wrap
each week that's what he was doing there
was nobody to fight I would say around
three weeks
[Music]
I know oh I know how dudes feel okay
listen I'm really indifferent without I
like to do right now I'm not really you
know like behind them right so but I
know how to do so maybe like that's my
champion get the win you know I really
thought he was gonna get the win but
he's not gonna be blasting out people
with the knee cuz they're not gonna run
they go tackle him real quickly and then
beginning of the match yeah tomorrow
tomorrow is just he doesn't care about
that he's gonna he's gonna play to his
strengths when she should and you know
um but Maas with all again he was
prepared but not obviously wasn't he's
always keeps himself in shape right this
is this is a new Mazda doll now so um
but he needed to be ready for the ground
game and he just wasn't no he just
wasn't but and that's it so it's gonna
be interesting or set out to fight
Island in Abu Dhabi you know yes salut
salut to the know crowd ready it felt
like it was more it felt more for me to
watch UFC tell us what you did why as
hard for us to do it for me to do the
UFC joy because it's just not the same
thing when it come in a ring and you can
hear them coughing and like no but he
gives it a nice gym feel yeah gives it
a different atmosphere and you get to
hear a lot more because a lot of times
you don't really hear the impact the
punches you don't really hear we're
almost almost and I and I know this is
probably not true but it feels like like
almost it like they're not in it as much
as you can tell a mother dogs coming
he's like from Miami he's hyping himself
up because remember all gladiators need
to fight off of the crowd switch I don't
like watching UFC right now I'm almost
finished in seventh we're gonna get into
I'm sorry but the reason why I hate it
is because I know a lot of dudes that
fold under the lights and use this gym
you come okay you know the truth use
that could perform perform and I think
Martha dollars a light dude and for
whatever retake it anyway so all right
so listen this is the thing that Dana
was having a problem with Oh football is
going to introduce artificial crowd
noises they've been doing it for years
but this time is going to be a little
bit more arm out there because there
won't be anybody there and then you will
hit artificial crowd noise yeah now what
they were trying to figure out is how do
they implement artificial crowd noise
and MMA right because they was trying to
experiment with it before was because
that was on the table tennis didn't know
he didn't want it mmm because it gives
an eclair advantage to either fighter
right what I would say is have a person
with like a Wii button come right so a
punch 16:05 uh some chat King based on
some hot room is out in the streets you
might have to get more than one storage
unit to store a new house bro boxes
andis
he said did that for you book event
solve we gonna yeah we have touch reach
again undercard over deliver the main
card was okay the undercard was the gem
you got to watch more unnamed fighters
for undercard fights trust all the Museu
elder
this mirror you got k oh yeah so look
man we got all that out the way let's
get it to the minute man while the
reason why a lot of us are here you know
saying we gotta talk about the amazing
Lord Giuseppe in the building man so
let's look let's get into it badly you
know you gotta talk about your video
game system history you know your
passion for retro gaming and of course
um as the top water type coders in Italy
you know say this journey what led you
to splash damage and of course becoming
the principal gameplay programmer at the
amazing games tactics Oh Lord you said
let's start from the very beginning what
was some of the first video game systems
you had and what got you into gaming so
I started with a PC so my first computer
was 286 machine like a so ms-dos and
that was so yeah I was 7 or 6 years old
maybe that was yeah and that was because
it was just stuff from my my dad's
office
we was an old machine by the standards
of that they I was just so this second
hand PC so yeah start there and I
started with them the first games were
like this weird you know I remember a
submarine simulator and because my dad
was big into simulators and strategy
games so he was a gay gamer herself like
okay yeah yeah it was mostly for him it
was a there he still games from time to
time but it's always like some grand
strategy kind of game so see if this can
stop so I guess it's six weapons a lot
of 26 players in there continued oh yeah
yeah from from there I got denied 486
and so on you know and but the first
games that really made an impression on
me where the first one was Prince of
Persia
that one was is my snake on the game
ever
Wow I actually played so I remembered
like sitting on my bed slit legs and
like trying to you know play the game
yeah that was like for me that that one
was like oh well there's this little guy
like moving around the screen that was
amazing and and yeah and and then I I
think another world bro
don't know you cup you coming from a
heart that's what I'm literally one of
my favorite games of all time made by
one guy Eric chahi
who I actually met for the first time
this year in person and on his that pax
2020 and I have a video he's a that that
game is like um talk to me that talks
about other world work okay good good
I'm so jealous I mean I'm a really big
fan that did that game for me was the
moment where I II I knew like okay I
want to do this yes
because it was like a movie you know yes
the credits you have the the name like
at that moment I knew like all games are
actually made by a people they be what
is so good the atmospheric storytelling
without really any narrative and you
just figuring things out in the world
right yeah it's just all it is is truly
a masterpiece man absolutely love that
game so that was the gate that kind of
sparked you a bit oh yes yeah and that
was actually also when I started later
on obviously programming that was the
first game I tried to clone as well I
start to move my own to the cinematic
platformer at the time does and that was
the yeah the first thing I tried and I
failed miserably I had the skills of
hairy face
obviously but yeah well that was it
really
and as I was saying before and for me
that thing that really changed was
during high school that the first year
of high school I think I got my hands in
on this modem so I got 66 K the Internet
yeah and from there I you know that back
then it was IRC and news graphs and your
mailing list so yeah so in in an IRC
channel that was about you know
programming and this kind of stuff I am
f1 guy and somehow this guy was older
than me it was already by studying in a
university it was studying computer
science and I I begged him to you know
to let me know more about like all this
stuff and he was like you know what if
you I'm going to just mail you something
I'm going to menu up a package because
yeah the modern was so slow back then so
I sneaked names and so yeah yeah I don't
even and didn't even knew like this game
real name like the days of AOL was just
like cool with read to people we act
like they're our friends when the dark
web was in your face way scary now yes
there's more people as well and the
package contained two CD ROMs one cd-rom
had visual studio 6.0 so one package was
Vsauce
obviously a totally legit copy of
business - completely legit or otherwise
abided by do you yeah and the other one
was game-changing as well for me it was
a cd-rom full of roms and an aim letter
called Genesis in one of the early
emulators expanding to this I remember
like there was a when when it was very
difficult to download anything on your
56k modem right oh yeah you you would
find alternative resources online that
was big so I remember a site that I went
to that it was called sell sold gone and
and it was just I stumbled upon it and I
didn't realize what it was until I
started flipping through like and I
realized something was up when it was
like yeah just email me and I'll tell
you what I had was I emailed him I was
like oh wow it was really like when I
say dude had everything it was
everything like my first order with him
was probably like $200 worth of I'm not
gonna say what did you had the genesis
talk to him so from there I started
learning C++ Wow and I started learning
dye effects and yeah it was diet x8 and
then 9 mm so the first shaders and stuff
like that mmm Wow Wow
and was it was it was it daunting at all
I mean cuz look I work at at T but III
tried by hand for a second program for a
second and just every I realized very
quickly I was not built for this wasn't
built for sequel databases I wasn't
built for a lot of this stuff like were
you I know the passion was there but
were you at any point overwhelmed
by like just coding and programming I I
don't think so it was mostly for me
because it was kind of my thing in a way
it was I I could spend like entire days
just trying to figure out something
really small like you know you know
moving up acting on the screen yeah yeah
but but that's back then it was I think
there was this element of you know
discovery as well at least for me
because it you didn't have like
tutorials on YouTube or discs and stuff
so the well this this group of people in
you know news grabs on origin charts and
stuff like that but they were doing
their own cool stuff yeah and they were
like sometimes like sharing this but
there was not not a real like community
for me it was just me trying to figure
out stuff out back then and so that they
really I didn't have like a goal okay
I'm going to you know the maker and a
complete game or something that was I
mean it was my intention it was all I
always tried to make like a this guy
ginormous game that was like oh it's
like impossible to do but it was like
something that it was just the miyabi in
a way it was just you know when you try
to learn guitar or something like that
for me it was trying to program my game
gosh so and I even started before I had
the internet I used like all these kind
of tools so for example you know I got
this software one time in our like a new
stance or something that was that there
was this other like game making software
it was called give me something remember
the name so yeah sure the very first one
I used was click and play from clickteam
and was they are already they're still
active they do this multimedia fusion I
think it's called it's one of the
earliest windows-based like UI based
game making
and then there was another one I tried
for quite a while it was called deep
game studio and that was from a Spanish
developer called immerse technologies
and that was that was interesting
because he had done a complete
environment so it had the properly
programming language so Pascal like and
then you had a map editor that looked at
really looked like the doom so you can
make like 3d environments Murray get to
him like mums so yeah I played with that
for a while but then obviously when I
when I created my machine to something
that had like you know a proper 3d card
like I'm the mother looks mystic or
something like that okay yeah but when I
started like doing that stuff and then I
with Internet it was like way easier for
me because it was I was suddenly I knew
about OpenGL and dynamics and I could
download the SDK from the Microsoft site
right and just you know learn this stuff
and there was the the language barrier
for me as well that's what I was gonna
ask like how did you how did you deal
with a language merit one and then to
was arm I had heard a story you correct
me if I'm wrong that you kind of also
kind of got to start about you sent a
letter to like a games magazine for your
interest to gotta get into so for us it
would be like the equivalent of like a
you know EGM or a game pearl and say hey
I want to compete like is that that was
true yep yep so how did you how did you
overlap so what for the language barrier
obviously it's something that I I did
like doing year the years so when I like
start my English got better in high
school but it was also a way to learn
English in a way so he was doing two
hard things at one time you were
learning English and learning
program that's incredible that is an
English is I guess it's the byproduct of
you know staying on the internet and
like you know at first I was in at this
kind of bubble of Italian like news
grabs and you know small forums and
stuff but then then ie yeah obviously
started looking at English stuff as well
and that was when really like open the
entire he said this with a real
criminals with the file fallacy with Jed
showing on the English clothes coast
listening to the Lord's perfection we
have a to 22 in the Chatham like sup
guys coming come on man Giuseppe his
props let's go rain know Almighty stops
was going on mighty Sparkle I was going
on he see some some great stories going
on right now so so yeah there's anything
yes tell me but yeah the magazine was
yeah the equivalent of PC gamer in Italy
so and yeah so yeah centre dis letters
to the magazine bragging that I was
doing out a new 3d engine bracket
embellish I was saying so I what I was
doing it I was ripping 3d models from
lots of games so I had like a few models
from quake ahead the back then was brand
new the model from Max Payne I think I
didn't right Oh
even before maybe but yeah so I had this
3d engine going that was capable of
loading like models in the format of
like the quake a few and three for me so
yeah it was I was doing that but it was
where obviously was nowhere near like an
actual professional to like but it was
like a fun project and it was it was
mostly me alone up
this point but then in in high school I
kind of joined another merde like me
that it was bubbling on you know web
development they was doing websites like
it's own gig and we decided to do to
make a forum for an obvious developers
in Italy
so we yep it was at 2003 I think yeah we
with it with it is this forum for
Italian speaking game developers decide
and and yeah from from there I met a lot
of people and I and and that grew kind
of grew up and went on its own way we
yeah that's what's up
let me I'd sort of back up one second
because I forgot to ask um obviously we
talked about the PC and getting it from
your gaming history standpoint right and
then I noticed you mentioned some some
submit hurdle of Mega Drive in there
right so what would the other what did
you by question is what were the other
classic games or consoles or whatever
that may have you know influenced you or
was it just a PC only thing like give me
some big influences video game retro
wise for you so I I had the I was lucky
enough that I even if I only had BC I
had friends with you know some friends
had the Amiga some friends at the my
cousin's for example at the Super
Nintendo and so I got to play a little
bit of everything and I and we also have
had an arcade just next to my house and
my little founder was a it was a very
shady place my story is something my
parents actually come they were like iie
yeah I used to play you know three
fighters to in their case or outrun
whatever and but yeah my parents would
you would really
they were not happy you were visiting
this establishment to play video games
they had their reasons this place was
like going back and uh no no now that I
know more about I like that so the
arcade arcade was still big for you as
far as going remember like when we know
we when we finally had Street Fighter at
home oh yes and you just stayed through
it all the way through as far as you
know as far all the way up into what
generation would you say did you taper
off at any point or like did you go
through the 16-bit the 32-bit era like
or did you just like um PC out like wait
where did you progress so I got I got
through all of all of them but for me it
was mostly the PC so catch it from from
that era of the 8 and 16-bit machines
and that was where I'm most nostalgic
and fond of so that's where I collect
like I collect Super Famicom and you
know mega dry games I saw the collection
so it's super impressive super
impressive but I get anybody listen you
gotta follow logic selfies Twitter
because he's got some retro stuff up
there it is classic throwback stuff man
it is it's so good so it's like you're
still able to find this stuff
I'm looking at guy right over there you
got a kind of brand-new copy of a ninja
warriors no yes
that was my love this latest yeah I
don't know
was there an arcade version of yes it
was an arcade version of ninja warriors
when you start hitting them in the room
they face are coming on they start
turning into robot yeah I played it like
last night okay because I didn't know I
thought they were human but like you
said when they took damage yeah and yeah
but just happy in your arcade because I
would play on 42nd Street and they had
three screens like it was the first
sixteen by nine game it was a show of
that game it's like it's insane yeah
they showed the whole screen so you were
able to walk to all three screens I
remember it because it was completely
different from what we were playing at
the time right and it showed like the
view because it automatically draws you
in but then as you playing as the ninja
and they start to take damage you notice
oh my god I'm playing with a robot over
time right and and that was like the
game changed because at first you was
like okay they're human but no the
damage that they were inflicting and
their robot so it was the first like
terminator yeah as a kid I was like
scarred by that I bet but you're right
like the aspect ratio right was so yes
at that time I don't remember a game
there was no game that had that aspect
ratio except if you sat down in the cars
like if you were using the cars with the
steering wheels you know you had to pay
to sit down inside so when when you had
those arcade machines and they showed
you the big swing but this was like the
first like stand up machine that had
that widescreen and that's why I stood
out to me oh yeah title song even did
like this kind of setup with the three
screens I think they was also odd
this game yes what had like this the
same kind of a super-wide yes being
going on
I never to be honest I never seen one of
the original CONOPS
around oh yeah here in in Europe and
especially in Italy we like the actual
original like going up with you know the
artwork that it was quite rare to it yet
very very rare I would assume expensive
too I mean such a unique setup let me
just get the super chat real quick shout
to say tragic a tree to ten hours of a
chat stop him by to show some love
salute and then we got stitch again he
keeps thinking we missing his chat he
said by Allah stupid [ __ ] King got his
tat why attic isn't wearing his uniform
that was not the deal
look addict is still waiting guy god I
gotta protect out he's still waiting on
the truck ahead that's the holdup so we
need the trucker had to complete
decipher and then um yeah King he's all
straight he just waited from the duty of
Edo bender man just at a tower thing
give him break he gonna put it up you
know say ILP only fans I'm just trying
to look for on ninja super famicom
version is or Super Nintendo version is
the the sequel yeah it's a completely
different game it's also like you know
it sometimes they do this sort of it's a
sequel but it's also a remake of the the
first game yes
and recently they did that again there
is a it's on switch and on ps4 and yes
yes it's pretty good as well the the
latest remake it's a they read thrown
the entire Super Nintendo game the
rugged then all the sprites they redid
the soundtrack inside that's what so
well so let's get it to UM Splash Damage
very quick and um I want to talk about
like how did that opportunity come about
and obviously like sliced it was a very
unique
the sense of they kind of have their own
eye peas and then they also you guys
also help out on like the big games the
Triple A games as well so like how did
that arm you know holding opportunity
come out and also you know what stuff
did you work on also during the process
day like I believe I think gears
franchise obviously we know tactics
we'll get into them pull it off just let
us know like the games you've also had
that involvement with on your journey to
success Splash Damage
so before Splash Damage I I worked many
years in in Italy even as a very small
game that we industry and especially
when I started right now now there are a
few interesting companies out there but
I started in like my I got my first job
in the industry in 2007 okay
so I I actually dropped University just
to get opens like I've moved to Milan
Wow and yeah so I told my parents like
oh yeah in two weeks I'm moving Wow how
did that go over sir yeah that was quite
a this guy yeah yeah just moved to Milan
either worked on a on a game that even
never came out I think I was back then
it was the the we has just come out
there was like the PlayStation 3 but
this game was still like in this
development limbo it was from for ps2
it was all the the black per se okay
okay so Google that that is probably
like a video or something by it was an
awful game games that you know it's that
specific era of video games of you know
show where when did you have again a
little bit of everything and it was like
a puzzle game was an adventure game Wow
shall be everything but yeah so yeah
and from there I worked on many other
small companies and I did many years as
a freelance in Italy as well gotcha
before leaving from for UK I made
several mobile games as well the free
iPhone for example I did the worst on
the Superbikes estates
yes I'm motorbikes
oh yeah I was actually a bit almost like
almost like in a MotoGP kind of aim yeah
I worked on these SS BKE titles and then
I moved here I moved here here here
being London here being yes lon okay
gotcha
yeah actually and I actually live even
super close to the office and live here
in Bromley and I moved here in 2016 and
i and i yeah i tried Splash Damage
after a week-long of interviews all over
the place in the UK okay yeah I got like
a free like a week out holiday from my
from a job and I I've planned this with
my then girlfriend and no wife actually
we yeah that was the we did this crazy
week where I will do one interview in a
different City Wow like everyday so it
was like one day was Oxford and then the
other day was Sheffield and the other
day was a lamington and then then it
goes on all gaming studios or yeah Wow
yes so because I did this few interviews
you know using Skype before like the
initial stuff from there I got like a
week worth of face to face face to face
interviews with with gaming companies in
UK and I was like okay that's so let's
try this and
I do this kind of crazy week when I yeah
it was five in threes in a week so much
so so literally did it come down and
splash damage and others or was blast
yeah I'm just kind of blew you away and
it was a perfect fit
so I ready new Splash Damage because I
was a big fan of one of the their first
game Wolfenstein Wolfenstein 3d was the
multiplayer part of Return to Castle
Wolfenstein I and I played that game for
ages
I played mods of that game I played like
so I was a big splash damage fund but I
yeah I had other opportunities as well
but yes roster damage really got me with
their the interview I did with them was
really different actually and it's
something that I tried to do when I now
I do interviews as well mm-hmm it was
really there was this human connection
with with the people I interviewed and
there was something that clicked so we
even talking about the Raider games like
doing either yes so I was like okay this
is a cool company I like the company
culture I like this mat here so yeah I
mean one thing about like I said just
looking at the site and a lot of the
information that Splash Damage puts out
day III again looking from the outside
in you know it seems to have a really
cool culture like you guys always seem
to be doing putting out these videos and
speaking to the developer as a very
family-oriented MIT just again looking
from the outside in so based on what
you're saying it seemed like it
resonated
you guys had that connection on the
interview and then you know the rest was
there so as far as you coming in you
some of the first projects was it the
gears franchise cuz I mean Splash Damage
is catalogue I mean it's you guys did
the Arkham series I mean you know
Wolfenstein doing it quake like you got
all the FPS and I would think you you
are you did like a seminar or something
kind of like um
explaining what makes an FPS feel good
and moving around so like what was some
of the first games as soon as you hit
the ground running with Splash Damage
that you worked on
so it was gears for it was given and
actually I got interviewed for another
project so they'd be presented a
different project we never got possibly
the prototype stage but so I was
interviewing for that and mmm and then
one day before starting working I got a
call and yeah the they told me like oh
it's fine if we actually move you to
this other project and they only say
that the codename brother I it was like
okay do I tell them that I don't know
what yeah sure oh yeah that sounds great
and then I and I mean I I knew there was
something ideas or related but back I
told that it was heirs Ultimate Edition
they was like oh he's one to me yes cuz
that was the remake yes oh no max much
one correct right mm-hmm
so I I'm I was like okay so I guess it's
going to be like support for the assault
omit or something about and right so
it's just our security got it
just out of curiosity I found this game
I found part two I've been I've been
searching the whole time that you've
been talking I've been listening and
paying attention but see here the two
three screens is gonna pop up right
there as you can see it over and this is
the actual one that's running off of the
C or CRT right here and yeah this is it
right here see how it has the breakdown
of the three screens and they had used a
special technology that it really wasn't
three screens it really was just two
screens mimicking a three screen display
and and just like you said the Nintendo
came out for turbo graphics it also came
out for Genesis
but they were doing part two so I found
part two like he said that was on Super
Nintendo and I actually found my arcade
yeah I just like to bring back your
classic you know Laurie is it a build it
man it's real quick you said before I
don't a dick he had a question for ya
yeah I was gonna ask
before you started working on the gears
franchise was was that a franchise that
you that you played or was it just
something that you heard about that you
never really had hands on oh no I
actually I got the next books 360 just
to play ideas so it was it's night only
now what was what was the feeling like
to work on a franchise is something that
you played years ago it's crazy it's
it's something that you if thinking back
a bit it's like something that just a
few months before I was in Italy like
doing you know mobile games and I was
pretty stressed out I was actually
working on on a PlayStation 4 game like
an indie title back then so yeah it's a
book bound Brigade it actually came if
it's out like it they are should release
it recently so it's a Metroidvania it's
a pretty cool game what that was
obviously like a super small team and so
it was completely different and so and
and it was it was something like I felt
like okay it's a derp now never because
it's like here I cannot really right
it's no room to grow so so yeah and yeah
the interesting stuff was that yeah when
I started so the first day I was like
okay no it's um actually it's years
before and that they I think they just
had their was like III coming up yes and
they were there was this mad rush you
know doing the e3 like fixing and they
and they also later on the they were
working on
we working on the multiplayer part for
the open beta that remember there was
like this big open beta event and so
that was crazy because it got announced
and I mean I I mean but I I didn't even
knew that Splash Damage was working on
Gears of War 4 when I joined because
obviously they you know NBA and all that
kinda stuff I wasn't to be assigned to a
different project so they they were like
okay but then yeah when I I was thrilled
I was like super super happy oh nice
just real quick I don't ask it because
you know we assume a lot of people sort
of like you know coalition is just hands
on with it like so is it a situation
where coalition says hey we need more
hands on deck
let's bring in splash them you guys come
like how does that work because
technically it the gears franchises with
coalition correct oh yes yummy the
Coalition is the the main because like
technically contractors working for the
game mmm yes and yeah we helped on the
multiplayer ice out of the game we did
many multiplayer maps we so even
post-lunch there was a team at Splash
Damage that did many of the years of war
for multiplayer maps for for a year post
lunch or something so yeah and then we
[Music]
when when we shift gears over for like
the team that got kind of split into two
so there was a part of the supporting
gears over for and another part trying
out this new project that become yes
topics gosh okay so you transition right
it as far as from for two tactics now
five dollars but before in tactics with
you yes got you okay okay okay fair fair
another team at Splash Damage that it's
working right okay let's transition
right on in man okay
Gee's tactics oh wow like just pretty
much you know so much to talk about but
obviously we talked about offline you
know how we feel about about the
franchise and stuff like that us being
like huge turn-based you know strategy
kind of guys but um
like just keep give me give me that
whole process there because um you know
you coming from a whole situation where
you know you have this iconic franchise
like you work for on for right it's
never been in this genre it's never been
in this I'd assume switching from a
third person to a turn-based strategy
game is a huge different type of feeling
right so you got this you got this new
IP you you guys responsible for this law
like like explain like how how how
difficult or that is maybe to translate
that into that that style of a game well
it was really it was tricky but we it
was also I mean it was kind of weird
because is a franchise that you can
really like the elements of the game
like this it's it's obviously its cover
based so there is told all that there is
already like you can tell by playing a
multiplayer match for example that they
have that kind of I need to flank the
enemy and it yes I can
there is all that the stuff going on so
it was almost natural to just you know
bring the cup and see like okay what's
going on here and it kind of already
worked but no you need to hire now the
the design and and that's like yeah we
get an amazing theme on the game button
on splash dimension and on side of the
the coalition and it was friend project
also because for us it was a game that
is actually well the past year years
games it's it was us helping out right
in this this project was this is you we
yeah we own the the game we designed the
game we create and
so let me let me back up one second I
thought you dropped a major point there
cuz like you said this is you yeah you
guys designed the game like how does
that conversation happen if they you
know the coalition comes to you guys and
say we want you to make this for us like
how does that happen that is a big deal
like to have this the responsibility of
this this is your IP right this is
Splash Damage it's a it's right so to be
honest I don't think all the I don't
know how the details there okay what
really happened from my point of view we
got this I I know I knew that you know
when when this kind of stuff happens
it's it's always like III knew that this
idea of you know the tactics games was
[Music]
someone at the coalition I I think I
learned that he becomes a the creative
director okay the other people had they
wanted to do this project it was from
them but I'm not just speculating here
after I got into the project when it was
you know this things happened in the in
the background and as you go find and
they go like okay that this okay okay so
like I mean but when you got the news
obviously to what it was and it is it's
tactics it's in this you know universe
like you know how how do those meetings
talk because from what I hear you know
this thing started out conceptually as a
board game that's what I was told right
so like this and I think it was on game
informer I I don't know I don't remember
the the site but if you google board
game gear star takes or something like
that it would probably come up with us
some photos as well and yeah one of the
the very first prototype of the game was
a we are designers this completely
functional board game by also reusing
the the miniatures from the Gears of War
type of game as well
pretty cool and and yeah from there you
could already see some of the concept of
the game already they're not working
yeah I got a question real quick I don't
know if you uh you have any knowledge to
this like when it comes to how closely
was you guys working with coalition like
was it like the biggest thing I think I
really have is like was there certain
things that they wanted like the
animations to go like the lore of the
game like was there a lot of things that
you would that your studio would
collaborate with coalition to come whoa
I got middle ground
right I mean the coalition is they you
know they are the Gears of War
developers so firstly they have to
approve everything and everything has to
be proper Years War right that you have
to made this year so fulfilling and so
yeah it was
and yeah the collaboration we had with
them it was really an song so they did
they were so legit let me I should quick
in reference to that like so let's just
say you guys conceptually had an idea
could the coalition be like look we
don't want this part we know what this
you know it's something normally happens
when you develop my game there for every
everything that goes into the game
there's probably hundred things that you
know in a way because like you have this
iteration phases in the you have there
is always like this thing especially at
the start of the development of a game
you you you don't know really what you
are what the final product is going to
look like you you can get your best
guess you can try you prototype things
you prototype certain mechanics you
process certain things but you there is
only one point in the development phase
where you could go like oh okay this is
this is working this is
right and you start like putting these
different pieces together and and then
you you get a game you get in this very
distant session like okay this is a
actually a game but before that in every
project it's not just yesterday since
there is this face of continuing
continuous discovery or you know what
you are going to do especially when you
don't are you are not working our direct
sequel of something correct when you
yeah it's a completely uncharted waters
you so just like discovery as you're
going on you're like okay this actually
works this can actually do this how does
it feel when you discover something that
actually works it actually makes it into
the game oh it's great it's it's a great
feeling especially when you see
something that the whole team goes like
oh this is a game changer give us an
example of such a game that was
definitely my question because it's like
when you look at Gears tactics like it
takes a lot of the conventions of the
next con game and sort of it fits them
in to be in the gears world in a way
they only work scored four gears like
the things as they were
overwatch the things you guys did with
like line of sight it it's different in
a way that you know looking at it from
the outside you like man I don't know if
this is gonna work so yeah I do like
appreciate that there like there's a lot
of people who like to take the XCOM
formula and do very little to nothing
but you guys like you took that you know
that foundation that they built that
game off and was alright what can we do
to make it gives light and you know you
made it aggressive because that's how
gears is you made a gory because that's
how gears is you base it around the
execution because that's how it gears is
like you don't really see people try to
you know you people see trying to that
not evolved right that that system I got
a question yeah right
who idea was it that after the execution
you get to have an extra turn because I
think that is probably
changing it forces you to want to get
that execution of so you can actually
have another turn to get your man either
back cover or actually back in position
for an attack or a flanker or something
of that nature and sometimes you'll get
put in a horrible position where you
have snipers on you and stuff he was
like the only reason the only way of
reaching them is if I kill at least
three these in some kind of lethal
groups of way and I'll said I'll have to
like throw a grenade and be like please
just go down don't blow up just go down
just don't blow I just told everybody I
don't have a name for that specific
feature I think it was just uh you know
as something that I don't remember who
was that usually it was this mechanic
itself but it was something that really
changed the game for us as well it was
one of those moments of clarity where
you implement something that you use
cover oh wow I could just see you guys
now like when you put that what I'm sure
I'm not a dead but I'm sure like when
you try new ideas and you play that
first build with that new idea you guys
probably look around like this is it
it's so cool because besides the the
executions that keep you going again
right you have that again let me really
this thing is overwhelming odds if
anybody won't play great tactics in the
realm when you guys get to play on
console and yes just know he wants me to
ask when is it coming to console I don't
know if he could ask that but they kept
bugging me to ask you that we'll get
there I mean I it's I mean they say it
soon
it's something I will go soon like you
you guys know in the chat he can't ask
that
but look the other day what makes it so
cool like I said the overwhelming hearts
to going again but also little nuances
that I like you guys like well I'm
playing
XCOM game I'm used to throwing on
overwatch a lot right see going
overwatch and pretty much anything that
comes in the vicinity
you can shoot not in tactics tactics you
have to physically aim your vision cone
down a specific path and you have to be
guessing it feels more realistic so it's
just not like this I could see
everything and I can react to everything
you don't say yeah I was my baby talk
about it I it's it's it's a feature that
I that I wanted from I think they they
won like it's something that we probably
tried to like doing in this baby
prototype a little bit by it's something
that it's one of the very healthy
features that I I knew that I I think I
needed I've noticed game game types like
that if they don't have overwatch I'm
automatically not as interested like but
even sort of cone of vision it was I I
already knew that I wanted to do London
wait so the was obviously discussion
with the designers but I think everyone
was very interested in trying this stuff
out it was one of the first thing I
implemented so I'm glad and you can see
in the in the when the game was
announced at e3 the very there is a very
early video of the the game and one of
the feature was the the this overwatch
cone yeah you know in a different shape
on you know they looked a little bit
different from the way we should but it
was like already there and that the bill
was really early on in the project
what would I appreciate about the
overwatch is like once again like you
guys didn't just take overwatch from
everything like you made it your own you
gave the cones and what I like is I was
talking to Cognito and what I was like
man is like sometimes I might be over
watching it has like these assault
rifles only I rarely go to the end of
the year the overwatch because I noticed
that if you go to the end you will miss
every shot so let I'll bake them in a
coal
quarters and I'll put it like literally
two feet in front of me but they think
the thing that's unique about it that I
want to give you credit Giuseppe it's
not only the way you as a player use it
it's the way the enemy uses it because
the enemy sometimes can have you dead to
rights but what they'll do is they'll
box you in three or four and they'll
have overwatch castle-like if you move
over there getting shot if you move over
there like the enemy is very aggressive
with trapping I feel like that aspect of
the AI is pretty brutal and amazing and
like I just want to talk about that
process of dolly again the enemy has so
many enemies right so more of them but
just this aggressive overwatching like
with that like how did could you explain
a little bit of that door progress and
so yeah or AI a team a was in this
project
and there will be a I think it's called
epic first soon there will be a
presentation on the AI system by Nelly
they are a programmer that will go into
details like don't own the end because
the another thing is that the enemies
also move all up at the same time as
well so the we have this many enemies on
screen because we can have all these
combo moves that they do where they let
me get on my nerves man they really do
I'd be getting so tight because like
they'll come out of those those little
emergency holes and then the first thing
they do is go over to my people I'm like
over watch them and the funny thing is
like though over watch them and the I
you know I use like an assault with an
investigate around it and then the
moment I do that they just start
shooting everyone else and I'm just like
wow this is the most aggressive a I've
ever seen up again I have a question
feel it feels aggressive but it's a to
be honest that I'm there are some rules
that are so for example they if they DB
Nou they cannot kill you in the same
term like oh that's interesting for
example when they have noticed when they
do overwatch they don't shoot you well
stay exactly they do that or another
thing is that when they they if they
just appeared so if they just dropped
from the sky or you know something they
are not going to shoot you that openly
hope you just what does that make sense
just stop you have a question is this
aggressive AI from the AI team a direct
challenge or a direct result of the
great game testers you guys had there
because I'm pretty sure like if y'all
had a board and he got past it the AI
team was like okay you know what ramp it
up a little bit more clearly got this
part right here this middle part yeah I
want a cypher here a sniper here not a
sniper here we don't want them pass in
that middle part is it did you have
great game testers or you know the
animation who whoever was on the
offensive side because I called you know
the AI the defense right so whoever was
on the offensive side did you have great
players there that form a fantastic
defensive AI team that I had to sit
there and get mechanics to to see what
they did to break down the game to make
sure because I think this tactics is
probably one of the tightest tactical
type of games that I've seen play or has
played so the whole QA department in in
video games it's they are like the
unsung heroes in a way of game
development because it's it's a grueling
work it's a sometimes like testing games
it's a you know it's not as as fun as I
am just playing the game it's really
almost like a testing and knowing really
the game inside out at that point it's
really you know going and um besides
that there is also obviously the you
have to the game is in development it
changed a lot and there are obviously
there are like hundreds of like buy some
stuff that
every time and so that's normal I gained
the element but inside that not only
have to you know find bugs and the repro
bugs and so on but you also have to play
the game at that level and by the end of
production yet we have some testers that
we're you know speedrunning the game and
there was people even in the in in my in
my team that were like completely yeah
they knew everything the new like
spectively
all the bills and you know I'll me out
to mean much a certain class or all that
kind of stuff inside out even stuff that
they design this were like oh you can
actually do you know how I knew that you
guys did it I was doing one of the first
missions is when the first boomer showed
up with the what's that gun called the
booster boom yeah the boom shot
I remember killing him I killed one for
shotgunner and I remember going up there
oh you could pick this up and I remember
the animation to him hitting it's the
exact same one from Gears and I was like
yo not to mention I hate those things I
can't every time they came up I remember
there's a boss flight I was on you guys
kept throwing one of those at me every
turn and I was like they know I hate
these things you mentioned a boss fight
so talking about the aggressive so
characters the boss fights were were
hair-pulling inducing sometimes Oh hike
how did you guys come up with balancing
those type those fights in the game as
opposed to regular campaign sort of
engagements so to be honest the boss
fights it we're one of the few aspects
of the game that I rarely touched only
[Music]
mission gameplay and you know I I did
the the character customization I did
some lots of these stuff involving the
abilities and the you know the
characters themselves the boss fights
were we had several we had like a few
people full
focused on on on designing the the boss
fight and making a school as possible I
was sweating I look like I beat him on
my second try but it was like one of
those things where it's like if he
doesn't die this turn I'm gonna have to
do it again like I want to just get to
it because my whole thing is again for
people who have not played tactician
there's a lot of our guy a lot of guys
in the world they're their console guys
and you know on PC we've got a chance to
experience this but it's like okay not
only is to productionvalue people
understand like the production value
guys are using for these cinemas in
between the game outstanding the
gameplay is frenetic it's fast you know
and it's overwhelming you got that
aspect like soft said the boss fights in
my opinion are by far the best boss
fights I've ever seen in any tactics
type of game so like for me I guess my
question to you what what is the part of
the gears tactics that you're most proud
of like that you are more proud of
either work and honor dealing with for
me I have to actually one of the is well
the one I'm most proud of is the the
combat really it's the nth moment like
combat you have the sheer amount of
abilities that you that you can send us
how and the whole fluid everything feels
so like moving your units shooting and
all its call these disabilities that was
something I really cared about no having
this keeping everything like this kind
of level of Polish and then 3d data for
me because the yeah as you say the
production values is you know I'm part
of mainline yes game big-time both have
Unreal Engine 4 - brother cinemas wrong
in us I guess 500 fantastic and that and
and yeah and then obviously you know
there is a lot of at stake there with
the coalition is that I they
during the years five and you know they
expect the yes quality from us as well
so and and and so having you know the
kind of sometimes in this kind of games
you you can cause an eye and you know if
your units are like glitching a little
bit and the know when I turn ants and
the camera like stutter so debated in in
in this kind of games it's something
that happens often in India studies was
like somebody that we couldn't tolerate
it was something that everything had to
be at the level of polish oh yeah that
was really hard even because the game is
also it's not greed based as well
right sure that we did heavily on just
goes many times as you can to use can't
go it till you run out of those action
points right right to what most most of
those games you can only move and shoot
on that game like it it's encouraged
like the way you put that you didn't
want to go with that direction because
you wanted outnumber us and you can't
outnumber us without letting us shoot
four times in a row baby facts otherwise
it'd be completely unfair shot the
squirrely Dan with the Canadian to
awesome but July 23rd is soon cuts for
the wind she's a huge tactics fan
Giuseppe
she said huge deer fan here and love
tactics great job hope we could get more
games in the future gears in this genre
chess makes you know was funny she told
me after she played that that she beat
the game first off which a lot of people
didn't and she told me that when she
played gears v she saw the battlefield
different mmm because of how she played
gears tactics and she said it made her a
better player in Gears five will make
now Giuseppe it's funny you say because
it's funny out excited too because like
is well-received is get obviously I
Castle guys okay they can't wait to get
ahold of it but my question is like how
did it feel when feel we call them
filled ominous offensive put them on
this Maxim correction correction bill
Dobbin is back to this soon to possibly
be Aurelius so that it's not possible
like king say we're huge fans of failure
obviously in a row but my question to
you is you know I'm a huge fan of the
genre and everybody we're all huge fans
of the genre right how did it feel to
get phil spencer to tweet
I just finished gear tactics you know
salute the Splash Damage soluti you got
like how does that kudos feel as a
studio when the boss is playing your
game and tweeting it and saying that you
guys did a phenomenal and you know it
was good man cuz you don't jump off
destiny for nothing exactly play destiny
so let's talk about how how did it feel
what was the studio energy like Guiseppe
oh it was amazing it was really like
it's one of the those things that you
know especially I know and a few people
in the studio are like ug Xbox fans and
they probably have printed that and I'm
pretty sure yeah it was really
incredible even because it's the kind of
things where you don't even it's the
kind of things that you don't even
imagine when you start like doing a game
like this know what one day you know the
head of Xbox is going to yeah I mean
besides the obviously the the marketing
for the game but that's actually like
personally he didn't have to you know I
should play the game exactly but yeah
but I mean I know that Phil Spencer is a
is a is a big gamer it's a really and
that's I mean it in a way it was a
surprise but it was also not a surprise
that he he cares that that much they
actually you know plays tactics isn't an
easy game it's definitely one of the
harder games in the platforms in the
genre so fulfil to be finishing that
salute to Phil ways gaming for anyone
who really finished that you know that
genre like that your iana shame to say I
had to redo it respect my characters too
was the acres that I did it was one of
those things where the first time he
beat me it was so extra I just said I
was like well I had to sit down I was
alright I didn't respect you when the
whole game and I was like I'm about to
respect every single person here and I
went in that's like I barely beat him
like my sniper cuz I was doing like half
his held every turn with that sniper and
then that last time I used every ability
I used Nate to put more points on
everyone I was like I'm killing him this
turn oh yeah because he's killing me
next turn the Lord said I have to ask a
question it's not gonna be nice but I
have to ask you what question is all
right the game was fun we love this game
however there's one aspect of this game
that I hope that you're not responsible
because I would strangle this person who
dumped out of this which is side
missions now granite when they first
appear on the screen I said okay I did a
couple of missions all right this is
cool
something different whether it be you
know free the prisoners or control
points and stuff like that and as the
game went on these missions started to
appear more frequently then they weren't
cited mission city was they were
mandatory missions that if I don't
complete them I cannot advance the
stumpy whose idea was this bad you could
be vague like we ate ours confirmed a
just if it was you just simple you're
still invited back but I have to know
there is one thing in this kind of game
I'm a big fan of the generous so I
started playing these kind of games with
UFO the original I even have a signed
copy Wow Julian Gollop Wow and and I
mean I am I I played like almost every
game of in this general really during
these years and and one big
that I really like in this January is
that this kind of the subtly I mean the
one thing is this kind of having this
kind of strategy layer and then you have
the your actual campaign missions and
rather that kind of stuff in in Gears I
mean the this but this having this
complex stuff layer really adds to the
overall complexity of the game and
difficulty and I think in India statics
they just wanted something that was a
little bit more streamlined okay so
there was more easy more story-driven
right very narrative focus just not it's
it's not to you know when you're doing
this and your opponents in the game i I
it's hard to nail like the perfect spot
where you know you don't overdo catch I
with you know with the Twitter content
be beside mission so you don't new you
still keep the or you you have a game
that is too short for example I feel
like actually because at the end of the
game that the the thing is also is when
the game offers you you have at that
point in act 3 you have all these
abilities you have your units you have
like everything everyone so that's where
the game actually because it's the most
fun in a way because you you can use all
the abilities you have like normally
stuff on life so I but obviously it's a
it's just difficult to nail down the the
perfect like length of a fee so
basically I think this you get I got
another question yeah I think that's the
people a lot of reviewers and stuff
because I read a couple reviews is just
like that it was mandatory but I know
why you guys did it you guys did it
because those bosses will be
overwhelming if you didn't you know get
them to play more content to get more
levels to fight the boss I think that
you know if you would have gave them the
option to skip it and get there and get
destroyed they would have went back and
did it anyway so but you're obviously
when you're when you're thinking of a
blank play because
the game isn't made at this point you
have to like you don't see it till after
it's done and you know I do understand
where people were coming from that
because it was it was bothering me a
little bit but the gameplay was so good
that I was I was looking past it because
I wanted to play the game when I got to
that last chapter I last shot that was I
was like yo cuz cuz you guys not only
were you made like doing having us do
the side missions you were putting a
handicapped on us and I'm gonna be was
like rules that we're gonna we gonna
send two people in there man take two
people you have to take like all right
this is the big December play I love the
aspect where because let's be real you
start like you say you start getting
overpowered you start getting the
abilities you can start handling the
battlefield right easy and if you guys
knew that see you say okay you know what
this last chapter we know they can
handle situation let's take let's make
them uncomfortable it was like the part
I did like is it forced me to take other
characters because they be like yo for
this mission you gotta use game or this
mission you can't use this one and like
it made you you specific things and I
was cool cuz I have my other units built
up I had an artillery guy he was built
up I had like a lot of suppression and
all that so I was good the only thing
that was kind of brutal Devery like you
could only use two people you gotta
evacuate them ten turns good luck there
are certain scenarios where I could only
get like all my member one it would be
like the random dude that was really
good but he wasn't a named character
yeah but that's good cuz I doing this
Bishop is out man he's done he's over
he's dead I'm not coming back for that
would you feel about that aspect of the
of the game desire yeah definitely I
mean if I I were to do another tactics
games I would like to focus on having a
more like a implementing this kind of
you know strategy layer that even if you
have this kind of repetition in this
kind of games you you your main campaign
in even in Xcode
sometimes it's like yeah wait that
carries the whole game 20 yeah I think
so you just have to find a way so that
in the the repetition of the missions
don't really wait on the gap is too much
because they they can actually choose
now you know okay I don't want to do
like a rescue mission maybe I want to do
like not always wonder those rescue
missions those people and they were
beasts every single time I rescued one
of them I was like I'm using him yeah I
think I think the you know the reason
XCOM doesn't have that issue because
they base building so when you do a
mission you feel like you have another
like reason to do the mission I feel
like you guys have you guys put all the
pressure on like the characters
themselves like you want to build the
ultimate character and what's the
characters are build it's like now it's
just like you're spending the last
chapter with ultimate characters just
trying to survive at this ball right
like so I do think that was one of the
reasons that that uh because this is
this is one of the few games that I've
seen like this that was built around a
narrative so that that really helped it
yeah yeah yeah you have other games like
like this but they are more I mean
there's another one I play that it's
called the mutant three year zero that's
funny that by its also I mean I love
that game but brutal it's focused more
on like you have this fixed characters
you don't have that many like you
there's almost character yeah it's just
a face and they focus on games yeah
the game is absolutely brutal because of
the permit uh that uh that game had me
so frustrated like if I lost the duck
guy I was the exact opposite I was like
the only one that's not expendable as
the duck guy say I don't care about this
dude like he was good with his mutant
level but I was like if he dies no III
got really because I've reset their game
finish that game yet so you know full
disclosure I reset it a thousand times
because they keep killing them for me
yeah I get really pissed off I feel the
hot new protagonist even doing yeah I do
think that you guys it's like you know
this is me this isn't everyone's a pinky
house the field I had to make a better
protagonist in the curb we gotta bring
Gabe Diaz back foot full four gauge
tactic to man you gotta talk to use
definitely good how you feel about get
hot studio feeling about gay mover
forward there's an interesting thing I
can say about Gabe that I in indirectly
I think I I named him in a way so I mean
they were doing our creative director
back then was doing a you know a big
list of names and see like oh you can
propose some names for the the main
characters and then and everyone else so
everyone was adding names and and III II
added Gabriel in English so I picked
that one so yeah confirm directly
possible forgave you the best
protagonist in Gears currently right now
[Laughter]
reminds me of like the over zeem of
gears like based basement great story
and I love the the work that the team
did on the characters I worked with the
character our theme was this great art
book that they did they did as well that
moving a lot of information and you know
the concept art and and yeah yeah i'm i
was daily like i was really amazed about
the quality that our artists just uh
right now and and also the the the fact
that the the characters are
fully-customizable yes because I would
put like silly designs I would have like
American flags with with dots and weird
colors and give people purple outfits
and then you see the with the sitter but
it was no full customization a lot that
was a lot of work as well because I
obviously have to think that even the
cinematics you know oh this shot doesn't
work because there is now a big shoulder
but that like you know the someone can
equip and all this so there was a lot of
work and there was this mad attention of
detail there that the entire thing was
really focused on okay this we have to
see this cinematic with this specific
armor on and if that works and they were
packing like you know oh this is
clipping with this other thing and we
need to disable this during the
cinematic and all that kind of crazy
level of the detail and care I
definitely like that chick from Gears
tactics the extra one she didn't think
she just did that you just BAM oh yeah
absolutely I so look real quick last
question before we move on be a lot of
stuff to talk about but um
there's a big thing going on right now
in the industry except I got to ask you
cuz you are the lord of coding and
programming he worked on games before so
I gotta ask this cuz uh Phil Spencer was
in the news recently and um he made some
comments and a lot of it came down to
you know game design and consoles you
know um people saying that they may be
held back you know I'm saying because of
you know work I guess with the series ex
situation you know that obviously
they're still gonna be supporting the
base consoles you know I'm saying so
being that you've developed before and
you've worked on multiple platforms
before like you know what do you prefer
do you prefer to work on the new hallway
exclusively
what are your thoughts or that do you
feel that gaming has changed you know as
far as scalability like what's your
whole top rocker this is like a hot
debate right now that the gaming
community so I'm just curious to see
what side you fall on here
I took me honest I don't get this I mean
I am it's something that always came sup
and they it's uh it's like this kind of
uh let's call them cross-gen games yes
are they have always been a thing it's
not like the first time that we have
this kind of mission it's actually
easier now because now the the other is
so so close that you can actually now
you can create a game for for ps4 or
Xbox and you can just make it run on the
next-gen console in a way that it's way
easier compared to for example you know
a PlayStation 2 game and a ps3 game so
but but the disc Ross gen games I have
always been a thing so if you I remember
like I mean even a GTA 5 for example it
or you know gdf for as well I think was
another game like that mm-hm
or I remember like you know the million
times the importance guiding me to from
like that kind of stuff and yeah it's
just something that happens because when
you these games take years to make so
when you are releasing a new console
there are you have to think that most of
the studios are not working directly in
a game that it's it's not it's not going
to be an exclusive for that console
because this is not the development like
three four years ago that was not even
you know the out there was not even
right locked down right so so obviously
they they just start doing start working
on lead on the previous generation also
and and that console still has a big
user base so there is no real reason
of you know abandoned right but let me
ask you did you think it's more so
because of the the inclusion of console
gaming now being more closer to PC so
that there's PC ports so that that
that's the reason why the the
scalability is such because I am gonna
push back on one question a lot of
things that we we are hearing is that
you know as far as the limits to game
design because you still have to worry
about the lowest common denominator
which is the the less powerful system
you know so like what what are your
thoughts on that do you feel that you
know game design will be held back
because we still have to cater to these
older consoles or you just feel
differently that it just game design is
different now like where do you stand on
that specific up so QB and I'm sure that
we will see some very interesting stuff
that will only be possible in the new
consoles for sure
but that's not I don't think that's you
know that's completely try to it's
something gradual mostly it's something
that at the start of the generation even
if you have titles that are only running
on that console right you don't have the
you still don't know what I mean you
know they did what are the possibilities
of that hardware but there is always
someone you know raising the bar with
something and then there's another
studio kind of you know taking that
technology and improving on that and
same is for for game design as well and
so game design specifically I think it's
even less tied to this to the hardware
then it's like rendering technology
stuff I mean you you really like the
other that we have right now is they are
it's so powerful anyway that you can do
almost any anything you can think of in
a way or another interesting there are
specific limits but it is you can still
do a lot like so what what is in my
opinion what
is helping back games it's more you know
the stuff is completely outside of the
hardware race it could be just you know
market trends and this kind of stuff so
we're you know now the production of the
three ball a games are like the cost
involved is so big that the publisher
obviously they have to risk less so they
have you always said this you know
sequel after sequel of the so I think
it's that's really what what helps back
in innovation more than actually you
know the actual are the limiters I would
actually have to agree if you're on like
I've been told by a couple of people
that would they've start process you
know sometimes stuff is pushed on it
because it's hot right now and then when
the three years is up that's the hot
anymore and so it's hard to really
innovate and make new types of gaming
experiences when you clout chasing the
the stuff that it's like for instance
like Battle Royale
everyone try to make a battle royale
game for years to this day people are
still trying so you feel just a clever
it again to clarify what you're saying
you you feel a lot of design is kind of
held back by market trends you would say
as far as like from like I just want to
bail down that more important what you
say well it's not held back I wouldn't
really use that term it's at least like
informed by it's kind of a loop as well
because if something is successful than
other will will try to like dive in into
that market and and this is it's kind of
becoming something like a bottle reals
for example yeah
it's it started one way but now they are
so successful that everyone is doing
them in a way or adding get that kind of
components into their games and and and
then we need something else that the
breaks this kind of look no we've done
another game that can change things I
think it's it's more or less the
question is
because people feel that the older
generations hold back the power or
whatever they perceive it can be right
and being at your program or being that
you have to program for the lowest
common denominator and the highest
common denominator always being PC
because pcs come out with graphic cards
every year that is $800 and above maybe
um
and you know and some silicon graphic
workstations that you have to get
yourself to to work on in your
environments because I'm pretty sure
their environments that you do use are
at least two times more powerful than
the dev kits I mean with the dev kits
that you do use are two times more
powerful than actual consumer units
because you have to have that
environment to move around and that
flexibility to see what works and what
doesn't what I'm talking about is like
when you spec you guys expect to like
the lowest end PC you know what is
acceptable for the lowest end PC and
then you also have maximum maximum tools
like tents elation and all that stuff
push all the way to the limit to see if
the game can run in that form so the
notion that it's being held back by
hardware you guys scale at all times
is that true sure but that's true for a
PC as well even if you don't make a game
that it's just a PC only you you have to
do that kind of thing as well you have
to run on like if you if you see on
Steam the the the average PC
configuration of like a gamer on Steam
it's not that powerful actually right
not like top and I kind of thing so it's
like a 10 16 hour or something like
guess it's a it's fairly low so you
still have to do that kind of reasoning
anyway right now it's just easier to do
on consoles as well because you cannot
you now have this park of machines where
you can go from 4k 60fps to down to
something that is like more that
resembles more like low mids backing on
BC so it's really it's kind of the same
right I just I don't I don't see this
this being like a really like an issue
and I'm I'm really soon I'm more
surprised that people think a long way I
can see their reasoning I can see where
they come from
definitely its but yeah to be honest I
yeah maybe we will see some like idols
that for example use the SSD in a very
clever way and it's something that's
only doable
you know like with specific tricks and
stuff but probably that is going to be
my guess is that it's going to be either
of you know a specific small first party
game may be or specific technology that
but then everyone starts using or
sometimes innovation comes from indie
games as well so that there could be
like a specific studio like doing
something really tailored to very
innovative and then maybe then something
catches on kind of do it start a trend
what it could come from there anyway
right because the thing is that's those
are the ones that can take the risk like
what we accepted was saying is like
there's no way a triple-a developer is
gonna take it it's very hard to separate
the financial conversation from design
conversation they make their mutually
exclusive they have to go hand in hand
right except when you're talking about
maybe at at the indie level right it's
funny cuz it made me think about I I
keep talking about the outer wilds and
King is like I'm not playing that
discussed in the game what game does
design things we can play that you just
haven't seen in other games right not
never in a million years are gonna are
you gonna see the new assassin's creed
do that it just won't do it
they will I mean up until minecraft was
made no one really was talking about you
know creative building games like that
until that game came out and when that
game came out it was so Dobbin it that
the big trip light I was like you'll be
got anything to because it's like
it's financial risk involved and let's
be honest companies want to make money
right they want to well you have board
members that invest their money into
your company and these board members
need to be satiated so you're trying to
balance creativity and forward-thinking
and also securing your company let's be
real splash damn it has to build a name
for themselves so it has to be
innovative but at the same time it has
to be profitable right so you have to
it's two crowds that you're trying to
please you're trying to please the fans
us right and you're trying to please the
board members them they're the ones I'm
right he's coming down the line to do it
again exactly because you have to show
what your product is when you go to a
board meeting I'm pretty sure like every
three to four months you're going to the
board meeting and they say well let me
see your ladies build and how is that
ladies build when you're doing Q&A
sessions how is that latest build from
the last bill that you did because when
you're asking for more money for
investors investors have to see the
product being produced and you have to
understand that when the product testing
is going up they see the trend going
forward so all positivity it's it went
up ten percent okay so we are willing to
invest 20 more million go forward
continue doing what you're doing type of
thing opposed to when you go back to the
Q&A session and you're going back to the
board and it went down 5% and they want
to know why it went down 5% trust me I
totally get it and I totally am to you I
just think a little bit definitely had
that part yeah yeah yeah and the I mean
the triple-a industry innovates a lot as
well but it's I think it's it's more of
you know if it's all about the
technology it's about like finding new
cool stuff but it's it's more driven by
by the the technology itself well in
indie games if you then they have to
stand out right in indie games have to
send out for something so there they can
obviously take more risks as well so for
them it's a win-win if
do something unique to you you have to
stand out from the crowd so basically
they double down on what you said in as
far as um you know in its crowning line
with what Phil Phil davon is Maximus
Spencer Sudhir which is he basically
said look every developer is gonna find
a line and say that this is the hallway
that they're gonna support we said the
diversity of hardware choice in PC has
not held back the highest fidelity PC
games on the market
he said the highest fidelity PC games
rival anything that anybody has seen in
ever seen in video games he said so the
idea that developers don't know how to
build games or game engines or
ecosystems that work across a set of
hardware there's a proof in point and PC
shows that it's not the case
so that's kind of the line of thinking I
would say similar to what you you say
would you say that and not only yes and
not only that its developers now are
really experienced on like actually
doing this back in the days of you know
the question true to and guess one and
so on
it was I every time the others changed
and there were even fewer engines like a
real engine that we're so widespread and
and used that supported like all these
different platforms as well so now for a
developer it's also it's just way easier
for us to support like console and PC
and even because we the industry as also
as set into this kind of a more
standardized like way of working so yeah
in a way consoles are a little bit like
PC it's basically the lines of my
playing that the only people really say
in this and it's not necessarily people
people were just height for new
experiences and I think the only real
people that you know state against this
they don't really have any knowledge
they just have past experiences that
they you know they go to the rises they
go to the the kill zones and that you
know Jin's after an engine and they see
look this is how things are but it's
like you said earlier it's like things
aren't the same as they were back then
technologies evolved and you know
and engines like the unreal engines may
be easier to scale everything so it's
it's more of people or just aren't
knowledgeable it's like I'm not a deaf I
don't I'm not always believe it it's
just more people are not knowledgeable
of how these processes are so that's why
they only go off their experiences right
they don't go off with actual ease in
real and reality right and to the last
questions have you like dude what do you
think is the biggest misconception
gamers have about game development that
we don't know what the hell we're
talking about
well I always love a little bit of the
it it happens often that the there are
this gamers that are really you know
maybe they they know a lot of like
technical terms and stuff like that and
they start into this kind of pop very
heated wars between like you know
obviously often it's like Sony versus
Microsoft whatever am i I see great race
expanded yours
yeah exactly yeah we go like like for a
feature by feature they go like oh but
Xbox has six oh but the SSD drive and
and so on you know it's it's crazy
because it's a it's something that not
even asked developers actually arise
about to say I don't think a lot of
developers know what they really can do
with these as the easier so break it
down what are we idiots Lord just simply
tell us call us we'll be talking about I
mean sometimes it's just yeah a classic
one is for example we we talk about game
engines right and you you talk about oh
how this this game is beautiful I uses
like the decima engine or in this game
you as a real engine whatever but most
of the time it's like these engines can
do exactly they use a very similar
entering techniques so they you know all
this stuff like you know screen space
ambient occlusion all of this sometimes
they are they are implemented in on in
different ways but the like
the rendering techniques that they use
are very very civil and so sometimes you
can swear like someone goes like oh yeah
I can see because oh oh this character
looks this way and it's like maybe I
don't know maybe the earth we are from
the same artist maybe sometimes I could
tell the difference between you know
your face ready that that's unreal
that's that you would be I can tell I
know boys yeah it's fun because you can
really do
I can probably recreate something in a
real and in unity and like pixel by
pixel they can probably much like
perfectly if I really like come into
that and I like you know I write the
custom shaders and stuff I can create
the same except phase in unity and in
the real and it will look exactly the
same
their pixel level almost so yeah but
sometimes it was someone that goes like
oh yes I this is this this game of this
specific sometimes it's not even related
to the the graphics itself it's like it
could be like an even a gameplay
mechanics and they could be oh yeah they
are using Unreal so the weapons feel
like look at that superior gunplay
unreal come find out if unity we could
talk to you for hours brother this is
great stuff absolutely love these tech
details we got we gotta move on an
accident that the question that we asked
every run before we wrap up with them as
far as um I'm either lower Giuseppe's a
top 5 video game or franchises of all
time any order any generation okay so
well my favorite game is as I said
before it's probably another world we
brothers bro over here we were honest
let's go yeah that that game is to just
the
it's obviously not nostalgia as well but
you know that's on top
[Music]
probably I'm a huge FPS fun as well so
the first week I was gonna ask you that
I was gonna actually being that you know
you were developing and doing stuff in
PC because the lines were fairly drawn
very early on with us so we were either
doom or quake so my question to you is
gonna be Quaker doom because I'm a
quaint kid right so so that was gonna be
my question to you and I love both of
them I formed I'm probably more of the
in the quake generation okay
gamers because you know it's the first
game I played in a multiplayer in line
with wow I remember like racking up this
giant telephone beetle nobody being able
to use the phone while juice every is
played by connecting like modern to more
them with I'm not mind that was a you
know the in another city so it was like
him like did the telephone bill was a
magic for me like yeah the first quake
and then the elf life franchise did you
get a chance to play it in VR oh yes I
actually like as soon as they announced
it I ordered my Alex we had a big debate
on that because we were saying like does
a VR need that that triple-a that bring
them in right and for you was absolutely
no question boom as soon as it happened
like right now I haven't played it in VR
yet and I definitely want to get it
because sovereign was you know like
praising it and everybody I hear praises
it and I just saw the new VR Gen 2 was
just released so
highly looking into that muses like $600
I'm trying to get into that but yeah so
alright yeah I saw your face light up
yeah
it works really well on even on oculus
quest and then you know the other
probably the oculus quest right now it's
probably the best advice because you can
use it on your own it's a step on like
things so you can play you know a beat
saber or something like that
hook it up to your PC and you can play
stuff like alpha if addicts so probably
that right now for the you know price
point and the the quality of the it's
probably the best choice to be an auger
so we got another world
we got quake like half life half right
no woody two more of course and then I
have to go for the into tactics generate
so it's definitely the original XCOM
series is a hero of mine so yeah the UFO
see is X Club you afford the fact which
was just the series is I mean for me
actually the one I played the most is
probably the second one terror from the
deep terror from the deep whether that
was salute salute
that's or serve a huge franchise huge
franchise absolutely and what well last
one to round out the 5 min mmm let's see
one last uh then I'll go into the Mega
Drive and let's see yeah against 30
years from yes that's a classic treasure
player shooter oh don't throw your
partner across the screen like you could
be scoped again with some cons what I
loved about gun star heroes and treasure
treasure single-handedly kept the
Genesis super relevant when the Nintendo
onslaught was in its swing because the
Nintendo arms what was in full effect
that super litter I never
get it and gunstar heroes made me go
back to that game that Dan dynamite
Headdy you know a lot of those games for
them yeah the heroes that's a classic
Lourdes every good story Roman salute
brother and the last one console only
one any generation favorite console I
would say obviously the the Mega Drive X
right away because this I especially
like the Japanese titles I mean it's
just that the output there the the the
difference in generous and stuff it's it
was crazy what you go yeah I say either
that or I'm also begin to rather
computing as well so I collect like all
these microbes especially living in UK
this you know the Brits off was oh yeah
amazing the the spectrum the the BBC
micro and so on it's really like dear to
my heart as well is they come with the
64 yes
alright now you gotta make you gun to
your head now tough choice that
Commodore 64 that Mega Drive probably
the Mega Drive fantastic brother it's
more like a it's an actual console so I
see that as a still a it's a computer so
the game is three all man just
tremendous tremendous stuff now again I
know we tend to run long we still have
to talk but if you have to go it's okay
but you just let us know I'm not kicking
you out they have to go yes buddy what a
real pleasure thank you thank you
approve or to simply Oh splash damage an
absolute pleasure to have you in the
realm
talk retro talk Cody so
his tactics talk how you gonna talk
about the sequel get rid of the side
missions no you gave us the release date
for the series X version you you gave us
all the information now someone's gonna
slip that one absolute pleasure be
hopefully Splash Damage has to bore down
Smith's covered up sued where could I
find people find you will you have going
on sir well I'm really active on Twitter
so that's my go to social media these
days was the Twitter handle was to let
them know let people know yeah bad
coffee
yes up to the description I guess I'm on
YouTube or something but yeah if you if
you just search my name on Twitter you
alright thank you so much man thank you
for taking some time you know you always
welcome back in the room and we like to
see like I said there advancement of the
studio we love what you guys are doing
and looking forward to hear for more for
you for the future brother definitely
want you back when the series x1 drug
yeah yeah I would look I would love you
have your battery if you had a roll it
to because um console guys man we don't
know what they're missing gears tactics
is absolutely amazing the story the
production values it's truly a shower a
game that translated well to the genre
and um we can't wait I can't wait for
about my brothers to get a hold of that
game so you're all welcome back with you
if we we get that eventual announcement
of the series X version on with the show
let's get this actually got last week's
poll results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with the recent
rumors of titles like Assassin's Creed
Valhalla we ratchet and clank drift
apart and now the medium or leslie
running at 30 frames per second will dis
prevent you perfect from purchasing said
titles the winner of the three-way ILP
poll at 60% of the vote is yes
unacceptable to not include a 60
frames-per-second performance mode
coming in at second
at 33% was know a great game can still
be 30 frames a covenant last place at
only 6% of the vote was I don't care the
PC master-race
throws 30 frames per second film at
gaming in the bushes all the lower to
participate just buy them on PC because
you know for PlayStation you'll be able
to get them on the epic game stores
going man obviously some news going in
look like a combo topic from both you
saw view and King and reference to the
dealings of Sony so a lot of stuff going
on whoever wants to set it up I don't
know if something would attack streaming
angle or if King was to attack the arm
epic deal that was me it was a big deal
with Epic Games right there with you
surfers it's not a it's not a big deal
because it's not a super model
you guys are not paying attention okay
about epic I don't care about something
that was good enough and it turns into
the boogeyman in the room and I didn't
get to ask what won't you tell me man is
man man is 10 cent everything go 10 cent
the fact that Tencent has their hand in
everything right now so further in
everything the hand that they have in
epic right 40 percent right but what
matters then what matter there is the
relationship now that don't cut them Tim
Sweeney salivating over the psy
I mean you obviously for 250 million
dollars that's a pretty good price so
you know yeah so that's a drop in the
bucket to Tim Sweeney hmm money is money
when you just finished a 250 is nothing
no no no no I told you the deal isn't as
big as people are trying to make it out
to be relationship that it creates
matters more than money right that's one
thing right you mean a junior to two to
the senior they walk their sons
I'll check this out some percent right
just finish talking about last week how
triple-a gaming right triple-a game away
Sony considers it that well their bag is
becoming unsustainable now they put
themselves into this I don't care how
much it is
they put a cut of everything moving
forward I don't care how small it is no
do you understand that fortnight made
400 million alone and April a month it
this year the world was burning in April
late
they made 400 million it does not mature
sony sony needs to figure out a way to
move forward right with with their
narrative while still being able to make
money that makes sense like you said to
appease their their stockholders you do
that you want my opinion let me frame it
and i'm gonna give it to you I just got
a frame what's awesome so basically it
says you know under the deal the
investment enables Sony and epic to
broaden their collaboration with Sony's
portfolio of entertainment assets and
technology an epic social entertainment
platform and digital ecosystem so then
it says epic confirmed they will still
be able to publish to other platforms as
known it solely is quite acquiring it's
going to be a 1.4 stake in epic which
means the deal values
about 17 point 86 billion now this the
last point I want to shout out
VentureBeat I said the feel is important
for Sony because it needs allies in the
upcoming console war later this year
Sony plans to launch of PS 5 in
competition with the series X but epic
has said that its Unreal Engine 5 and
fortnight will work with all gaming
platforms as epic has generally been
neutral when it comes to cross-platform
tech if Sony gets any advantage from
investing in epic it is it clear yet in
this deal so I just want the free look
all I'm saying is not what saw of saying
you know solves just talking about he's
being the the the side porn person I'm
talking about the people on Twitter
they're acting like a lot of people are
acting like that because they bought the
that this this 1.4 percent of the
company so they're gonna start randomly
having huge amounts of influence of what
they're talking about 1.4 percent isn't
even let you influence the top of toilet
paper they've got a marina worry - it's
off st. solve is a hundred percent right
in his point if I refer to these fanboys
on Twitter that are literally acting
like the first off none of them cared
about 49 per year this stock they
probably took whatever lucrative money
they had lying around they invest in an
epic because guess what next year they
gonna start launched and they stuff an
epic and they gonna want that stock in
epic because it's going to make their at
their actual store more appealing to a
lot more people and they're gonna get
more money in the long run because
they're using their own image to make
their image better and they have their
own stock in them to get them more money
and then you gotta remember too that
they lost out only you because $0.10
damage Splash Damage is owned by it so
you had a bid on that but they
they lost to $0.10 oh yeah has a hand
and everything no sovereign no you're
100% correct right not taken away from
your aspect of what how you see it right
I believe that the Unreal Engine is
definitely in a whole different
stratosphere if anybody's looked at
Disney the mandalorian you understand
that the Unreal Engine 4 was actually
crafting that world that you saw so if
that world to you looked amazing imagine
what the Unreal Engine 5 will do now who
own Studios Sony whose are lacking in
studio so we would like to have that
technology here because we understand
that is a shift in moviemaking right so
we will put out our hand in the bag here
so our hand in the bag is here
Sony like you said Jim dance moves Ryan
is definitely looking at a field ominous
Maximus soon to be a really as Spencer I
like to call it the Geppetto Pinocchio
effect right seeing what happens what
happens with Pinocchio Jim dance move
Ryan he's mimicking what Geppetto says
no photo can put controls the strings
you saying Geppetto has his hand up his
back now you must notice not well
Geppetto actually does the marionette
stuff you know he pulling the strings
when you're looking at it on the surface
everybody notice a Power Move did you
yell out it was a Power Move when
Microsoft brought physics Oh have it
yeah yeah and a havoc engine when when
they actually are in every single video
game you're talking about rise until
we're done
Microsoft get a cut yeah they every
every time every time god of war
something sells Microsoft get a cut oh
alright so you're not out shout out to
Delilah HD breaking nose WD I guess you
be something's going on
watchdog Legion will support smart
delivery thank you you be self available
so now that you have to look at it in
that aspect
beautiful you'll be suffered a Rodimus
got any confirmation chat Phil Dominus
is at Ubisoft talk to us check because
we're doing the show so we need John to
inform us
that is that it's got a big news better
beginning right now okay okay
yup so just said it fills Austin here
which we have to understand is Sony must
be viable you know going into this next
generation nobody was yelling out when
Microsoft make the deal with Facebook
let's let's keep the same energy these
companies are in the business to make
money fast right so one point two
percent fifty million is a jzc in the
nets everybody saw jay-z una nets no he
didn't had a seat in arena and he was
not looking at the bosses that was up
there
mmm-hmm looking down so ten cent is up
there looking down at jay-z sitting out
Sony in the arena you you and Beyonce
watch the game I don't believe that that
whoa probably next year when intention
actually tries to purchase epic friend
that actually happens and then you know
that Sony deal is definitely off the
tables then you know they get the cut
they get their money somebody posted
seventeen point two billion o 250 made
seventeen point two billion is work no
no listen you sideshow stockholders who
said 250 million investment I don't want
to burn them into the streets but if you
look at my timeline you understand that
people take false information and want
to go loose with it mmm
at worth 17 point something billion okay
now in that they have a stake in that
and what happens when they make more
money their shares gross or whatever
shares that they did get from their two
point two hundred fifty million we don't
know right but do we know how much money
did he gave Microsoft tell you you
deserve service no we don't know this
right you have to stop picking and
choosing who you Lord what deals you
Lord and what deals you feel is
beneficial when the company is trying to
survive and trying to move forward in
the ever-changing world this is the
great deal
them right EPIK right now has the number
one engine going forward for this
generation they had it locked narration
and they beat out a lot of other engines
unless you have a custom engine yeah
even in the same playing field there's
good that they give it to you for free
and send after you make 1 million some 1
million copies then we collect I don't
know works like that there's not really
so confident in their engines yet they
can do that so Sony needed to do this
this is something that definitely works
in favor of them does that give them
gears of what do you think gears is
coming you know stop thinking that it's
game-related as far as you're going to
get a game produce fully by epic soap or
a Tony it's not how to deal works the
deal works is they got a seat at the
table they get some coffee deals that
are being made stop only stop with the
Frog and then the thing is when it comes
it was it was it wasn't a PlayStation
acquisition it was the sony acquisition
but so the thing about it is like it's
like King said like when you talk about
where epic wants to go epic wants its
hand in all kinds of media not that's
just the same with 10 cent right so it
is that thing where it's looking at the
bigger picture Gaming is a part of it
right and obviously when you talk about
epic you immediately think epic game
store you take Tim Sweeney if you think
about on your engine so that that is
definitely something and I can say like
they'll be they'll get a little piece of
that pie and that's what they need again
to sustain their narrative moving
forward you know they're not gonna turn
around and say yeah you know you know
guys you're right like triple-a
development is it's off the chain we
can't sustain it they're never gonna
tell you that right and ever let's do
that
they're gonna figure out ways to bring
in more revenue right Wow continuing to
just say no this is our path forward we
can do this so this is just a way of
them to keep continue bringing money in
from the sidelines and keep moving
forward with what you know people expect
from Playstation
I want you to put down in the chat
because of you you're one of the biggest
cappers
for the chat you tell me what benefit
the Sony game division get from having a
1.2% fake inside Epic Games I I really I
really want to know your perspective
because in this will encapsulate the
fanboy mentality that is permeating this
for the universe right now I want to
know what you think is gonna happen with
what they invested and I want to shoot
it down real facts about it is is that
like I said the relationship it creates
that relationship where you guys are
already in bed together right you may
not be fully in bed together say he said
no hole he said trust me
Sony making moves well epic move to put
their games on daddy rules to stop a
king shaking my head they know the
intricacies of the deal Danny stop
trying to be Chris you be Danny and try
to get Saudis attention that's what he
said epic was trying to was trying to
get the Little Miss wait a second yes
like a fly swinging past my window while
I'm driving a hundred miles an hour
do you really think that epic was trying
to get you think so he's Big Dawg glad
that y'all saw this I'm glad that y'all
see it he thinks that it needs to get so
me oh look guys move it what's the late
great prodigy song
this is their duty analyze this survival
of the fittest kids they be allies look
at the end of the day I'm not bad man
look do you live investment you know I'm
saying you know a relationship you know
as far as do you know an engine whatever
obviously so I know it's only one point
for you know people going that but I
think it this way I look at it
I look at it like and shove the hip hop
cos if I've came so I thought it was
interesting you know I'm saying that um
you know we saw the spider-man Miles
Morales box for PlayStation 5 and you
know they got the white cover I do not
like the white cover I'm not feeling the
white but um you know I'm saying like
what I do remember is you know at the
top I'm used to only on PlayStation so I
went dug in a crate I said let me look
at the spider-man box the original truck
ps4 put it up put an image and put all
the image of the PS 5 miles round
without it and I just put this face or I
think I put eyeballs like wow only on
PlayStation where you know kind of like
alluding like where's that act so the
Saudi fanbase is coming for the kids
that it's coming no listen man they
already said they're not doing that no
more
you know seeing it is this PlayStation
Studios I said look I get that that's
true they said that the little box now
PlayStation Studios but here's the thing
no European vite vite vice-president saw
has said yes we will show this logo also
or other platforms that we attend this
to be a so when he said other platforms
I'll go you basically told us what's how
about to happen so again this is hot
y'all might get the ultimate no-go
because he specifically was like yo you
know right now didn't get a chance to
put the new logo on last of us to and
what you call it I'm gonna it time but
it's like move for when you see this
PlayStation Store Studios logo then this
it's it's anyways the type of quality
and it will be on other platforms also
so when I hear that the writing on the
wall as far as games going
on a PC to me so I just tell people look
we got a star bracelet ourselves now as
far as this exclusive talk there's a lot
of talk about exclusive this is an
exclusive that I'm saying
so y'all doing it too you know they
people want to make money that's just at
the end of the day so when I look at
this move this also what I did talk
about the kid what I think is this let's
be really smart business sense right we
know steam is the number one thing out
there but it's pot business is to say
hello let's get a relationship we
already got a relationship with epic on
this this engine you know I think what
it is is Xebec was probably willing to
you know promote their stuff on
fortnight and stuff like that they
they're the underdog and I think
PlayStation like Loki feels like they
can Loki manipulate them because they
cuz their mr. Brandes soul quality that
they feel like they get it right quick
get at me see now that's gold post
moving my brother I can't act that's cat
Danny
you said get at me with his day got set
get things that gets me mad about solely
fanbase and I love you Danny I'm in the
middle of talking to Danny did you get
them all I'm saying is everything that I
gotta say it realizes is to be honest in
reference to at first people were saying
it would never happen right then it went
from it's never happening - okay well
that's a three year old game for horizon
zero dawn right now we don't see only on
PlayStation now talk to me when it's
dandy you can't keep moving the
goalposts
you said I'm saying let's just be real
it's happening so stop capping and just
accept it that's not it's no big deal
but what it is is people put themselves
back themselves into these pockets like
yeah we ain't never gonna do what they
do dogs it's about money that's what
this is so let's just get out the fields
now you get your man go get your man
whatever you try to guess it's an
assassin's creed of anjala coming out
November 17th
I accidentally accepted that look I get
it you guys joke around in there but
don't call people corporate slaves and
stuff yeah when you say it in color than
I can see because when years when you're
doing
the bushes I'm not singing in the bushes
no I'm going to look in the bushes for
most of the time it's definitely gonna
be Christopher hard you know why because
Christopher that's who he was attacking
his curse listen the father comes ahead
week after week week after week maybe
sometimes two or literally the voice
right and he takes it and he gives it
and he's highly respectful until people
get disrespectful with him it don't be
disrespectful when I'm in and I capped
for Christopher Hart more than he's his
so-called generals I unions of trips all
that corporate slave stuff don't man I
don't came out of that at the end of the
day like I said we just got to be honest
we gotta we gotta get out of feelings
this is the way things are going you
know that's how well I still have I
still see people on Twitter saying that
it's just horizon you know it's gotta
use my authority that something's
happened Oh everything coming yeah buddy
I'm from great authority that
something's happening and what was funny
is remember back in the day when hope
was on here we were talking about deaths
training I said look they let the
aquatic dreams I peace come over they
have to do that they're like I don't
know about that I was like they owned
the debts Trading IP they didn't have to
do that it's about making myself the
last thing last play with this is just
that I think this opens up a
relationship potentially with epic store
as well right for getting those games
even if they don't come dandy right to
get in those games over there at some
point because again that's a whole
marketplace that's a whole base we've
just seen where horizon zero dawn was
over there own steam it stock to move
right it was up there and I'm saying you
see it be like people they're in the
business of making money they may not do
it day and day initially but Dave this
is where it is I so that's all I want to
say that I didn't get your balls off and
then we good in finish let me go ahead
and start because I see people on that
in the chat complaining look like it is
okay to joke around with each other but
if I feel like it's disrespectful X I
will shut it down he heard that from
somebody that was Owen Thoreau
over them down far cry 6 Oh put it out
there Oh got my man from Breaking Bad
Gus as this is the jail yes a little bit
look we'll move I saw everybody get your
balls off yeah yeah I mean it look that
really seems only gonna grow you have to
understand also that it's only is still
they're gonna grow these relationships
right but at the same time they're never
they're never going to directly two
things right Sony is not a direct
competitor if you if you think about how
often Tim Sweeney attacked Microsoft and
you WP antler Microsoft Store it's
because they were gonna be a direct
competitor to the epic game storage we
didn't know about at that time right at
the time Sony doesn't have those
aspirations those are the guys you're
gonna get in bed with right now because
you can supplement them whatever you do
you feel like this relationship they're
building will eventually make because
like right now horizons coming on Steam
do you think that this type of
relationship they're having will
eventually make it to where their games
are exclusively on epic game store
because some big I mean like you know
what kind of kills me I was thinking
this morning like they are isn't steam
doing some type of role where you can if
you have if your console if your games
not on their contour at their platform
you have 30 days you're you just not
going on that platform at all like I
feel like this low key like like that's
messed up and I don't feel like no one
even bringing that up but you know
that's besides the point like do you
feel like that rule will prevent them or
do you think that they'll get such a
good relationship because they're having
you know because they're buying stock
you know they're talking with each other
they're helping about that they on row
engine I Loki think you'll start to go
don't be surprised if after a couple
titles it's all on epic like I'm really
thinking that well you see this on the
exclusivity window yeah a window that's
you can't have a window anymore cuz
Steve shut that down yeah
oh you have you have 30 days to get your
stuff on a platform or they let you in
the clay letting you to Club yo no but
look you can't pick those that Steve is
out here moving again you can't really
like steam is no matter who you are it's
tough these these guys have spent more
than a decade building I get that but at
the same time you know there were stairs
you know you put stay to decay or not on
steam you know people will be upset but
it stated okay it's a good game it's not
great but you put got a walk straight
back up that Club I will give you this
addict we know epic is known to back the
truck up for exclusions and piss people
off so it's possible you know I mean
again you'll start seeing any deals
right because let's be honest Sony
doesn't have a place in the PC market
right so in order to make that foot hole
epic is gaining ground mm-hmm get in bed
with them now yeah put your stuff and I
say day and date I really don't care
because it doesn't affect me at all and
it should never affect any game or let
them blow up you because you should
never be pocket watching individuals to
that nature that's worrying about where
they purchase in a game I'm always shame
you guys I'm gonna keep shaming you guys
there's only four million dudes as valid
I honestly feel and I hope a smooth run
you don't like the name fix it well hope
you're watching because if you were to
put last of us to Nick eight on PC the
same way you put it on the PlayStation
they're full million would have been
something like twenty fifty million
something of a weird unheard-of number
you have to stop locking yourself behind
these old arcade views and thoughts
because it's not beneficial for your
longevity you're in the business to make
money and not coddle these babies let
babies cry they're gonna still be
sucking money while I cry yo yo yo you
interrupt you for one second Christopher
Hart I don't usually read non-super
Chapel Christopher Hart I do not care
what people purchase a game or where
people purchase again that's what he
said I just know the best the best
experience for the PlayStation games is
on the PlayStation console I'm willing
to bet you I'm willing to bet you 20
bucks that if I went back in your
history I will find some form of fashion
since I don't need an Xbox I have a PC
I'm willing to bet you I could find this
Christopher I'm not gonna look
categorically incorrect like we're
prizes erode our releases on a PC like
that I'm willing to bet you if I would
do these table chats
don't make me Christopher Hart just
admit it you feat you you you're being a
fraud right now Christopher let's get
some fraud alerts in that check for our
old boy Christopher
look man a today he could choose to play
way what's the plan it really okay my
dad but um look look I said we would
definitely see em expanding into you
know PC and hopefully like I said we'll
see what happens with the epic store
very interesting let's get the last time
but we gotta move um sir the final check
can't wait to play all these Sony
first-party 60 frames per second on PC
good job Sony put them in there Mikey
put them in there I wanna say just
passionate continue we have a manual
with the $2 super tech they busy hating
on Xbox while Sony is busy copying yes a
man whatever makes you that I'm not even
mad at the copy no more like it you
gotta make money you have to make money
it's just the wall garden stuff listen I
younger we loved it too like oh my god
you have this game oh we don't have that
game I get it it becomes a dumb argument
when you're 40 old man arguing about it
like I don't get it like just buy
everything and shell out them them
pocket read we do pushups
anyway let's get the last J going I'm
get a body here Lord addict man home
Xboxes and WB sitting in the tree man we
first off you know obviously everything
we're about to spew as fear speculations
you know there's a good chance that this
never happens but there's always a
chance that it does I would say the
chances like 10% but so let's get on to
Warner Brothers announced a couple weeks
ago that they were in the option to sell
ATT's clearly so much in debt they want
to appeal the like the last minute
appealing some of their investors so
what I want to bring to the round table
is at the time we didn't Microsoft
wasn't interested it happened weeks ago
yeah I think we even talked about it so
but now it looks like Microsoft is
actually interested in there and open
negotiations along with Activision 2k
and EA keep in mind that Warner Brothers
games WB games they own stuff like they
own the the Mortal Kombat franchise they
own the studio that makes work ha but
they only I people not the license to
stuff like shadow of Mordor in the
Batman stuff they don't own the the you
know the content that's in these games
but they own the IP
they would have to renegotiate the
license that they did purchase these
studios to get the access to make more
batman games and shadow I don't think
shadow for Mordor anything like I don't
think that would be in that contact but
what I want to Bri is like is this
something that Microsoft needs yes do
you think this is something I personally
me feel like this is the perfect fit
obviously I don't know cuz it's a lot of
money four billion dollars a lot of
money no no especially for do
what I've blamed them for not built is
Spain for billion dollars and doesn't
include license it's two to four billion
so it's anywhere from that number two to
four billion so I personally feel like
there's there's a lot of scenarios first
off they need another studio that makes
this third party get person games that
Cognito so loves hahaha Rock Steady's
perfect what you need to do is plug your
video up honestly because if anybody
doesn't understand his views on this he
has a video up right now
that's elaborating on these exact view
so you're gonna get a brief synopsis of
it but he has a full video up on an
attic channel please definitely check
out that video because I watched and he
made me think completely different with
a couple of topics and it's like you
know when it comes to they need someone
to make killer instinct
it's I honestly think the reason they
don't make it is because they don't have
a full-time Pathet just makes a dead
fighters if they bought nether room I
think the first thing Microsoft would do
was approve a budget to make a killer
instinct versus motor call me crazy and
I think that would show people like yo
we own this this stuff now we own
everything like if they buy them I think
the one IP that does come over is more
combat right that's the one that you I
think get witnessed I don't think
anything becomes exclusive no I that I
completely agree I think if they get
them you say Batman's come in every
platform you say whatever WB Montreal is
making is coming I think that if that
happened I think Batman would order
multiple platforms I don't think Mortal
Kombat would I think that studio will be
making killer instincts and Mortal
Kombat's
yeah killer instinct going over without
mortal combat going right I hear what
you're saying and definitely understand
exactly what was going to Lou to that
everything of being game pad but you
guys got to pass right to me if I if I
had it the way I would appreciate though
obviously I'm just you know one person I
don't have no no marketing background no
business background but I feel like they
have
a lot of little stories that make Lego
stuff let that go third part because oh
yeah yeah that stuff they you know
quote-unquote I don't agree with the
term but game past filler it might
appeal to some people sucker to Bill to
everyone but if you have all those
Studios making all those sooner or later
you're gonna appeal to everybody
well my view on it is this is 15 studios
right so it was kind of weird can
somebody give me a minute ago about you
know Microsoft point out like a boatload
of studios I was like yeah I know about
- I don't know the hell are you talking
about but again and then I get weird
dm's likes told you so um but when in
seeing this now I understand how it will
be bracketed off and it will be in tears
you have the let's say the lower half
and I'm not I'm not disrespecting any
developer because I don't make games I'm
not
we can't even remotely right will be
what I'm gonna say is like let's say the
popular developers right let's say you
take the lower and you have those make
this is 15 to break them up for sets of
five they will have a turnaround on one
or two year old games right so they make
games to keep generating content inside
game pass right so those games could be
episodic could be whatever those games
inside game paths then well all of them
will go to getting pass but then you
have the next tear game studios which
would be anywhere from two to three
years or two to four years games those
games will be the mid double-a games and
those games will make it to game pass
and then you will have the last set of
developers which will be you know
anywhere from you know four to six years
in development type of games with
triple-a sony type titles or you know
high-caliber Microsoft type titles that
take those five years those four to five
years to develop and don't that doesn't
have to have that pressure on them so
they're able to cultivate and do what
they do and the other ones in the middle
is able to do what they do in a time
frame and are the last teams is able to
do what they do in a time frame we're
also keeping in line with the nine
studios that you do have so there's kind
levels of creation being done inside
game passing a level of diversity from
every studio contributing will take game
pass to a whole different Netflix type
of level that's my opinion of it and I
think that's the benefit but the biggest
question is does Satya and Phil because
the the one can't move without the other
they have to move together right can
they convince the bigger company
Microsoft that they can take the Xbox
brand and put it on equal footing in the
Microsoft equals ecosystem as far as
pair two pair can can they convince them
that this four billion is two to four
billion acquisition of these studios the
WWE would put them in a position because
they're a software company that they can
actually look Microsoft the parent
company I to I in general generating
revenue through game past X cloud and
Microsoft services Xbox services can
that stand and if they can convince them
that than I think that purchased in an
acquisition happens without their
convincing I do not think that
acquisition happens I think the only way
Microsoft usually don't spend billions
unless they can make more revenues than
just than just gaming yes Mortal Kombat
I think is one of the things that they
can make just game because obviously
there's movies TV shows etc etc but I
don't know if that's enough to validate
if they have to spend four billion
dollars I know and to invest into the
ecosystem with game fast maybe they're
willing to to take that kind of risk
because that's a lot of studios that
they bought Warner Brothers I don't
think Microsoft has to buy anything else
when it comes to you know I think
they're done I think they'll get to it
because to me I personally would like
them to you know if they all were
multi-plate that would you know that
would be a little bit more disappointing
but we can't act like you know if
they're able to get these licenses equal
Batman Batman's being game day in one
game past wouldn't be relevant as a
would you know not to mention the people
that make shadow of Mordor they're
talented studio and they got the nemesis
I just want his knees he's saying it
isn't same private your tax but can I
could I do the pit I just want the box
of these cuz he's saying that it horizon
to West would never go or PC to get him
not there's no make that better what is
this IOP one 166 okay we do this because
you're coming into PS 600 key for a
couple seconds love are you could be the
first person to get Cognito sneeze or to
the face I know how would you feel them
hard to be the first person to get that
arises or to quote but no he said he
said it retro zero two won't be all PC
to PC PS 6 we got it thank you thank you
we remember to document 166 and if I
lose I put my knees on camera if you
news you want to figure out the week I
got to figure out how I lead to you know
knees check you got a [ __ ] you got a
super chat your knees if you would you
lost restored Hades with this 2000 which
at Ubisoft show was good for Christ six
book events yes then we have the Eagle
with the $5 super chat got a disagree
with you on the last one cog
delusional insinuation is not exactly
equal passion about Christopher Hart
lady gamer
donations include a 10-year exclusive
license period filled ominous maxima
soon-to-be Aurelius with WB gets a
crossover fighting game exclusive killer
in traverses more called the high
quality Deb's and more no doubt no doubt
then what do we get the rich are from
restored Hades seems like so many people
won't walk down that path that they
would make it all exclusive at the end
of the day Xbox needs to compete against
spider-man they would be buying club
they won't rain club I completely would
be playing PlayStation rules okay I
necessarily because I don't think they
would keep that to themselves I think to
me personally I do feel like if they
bought WB and they were able to maintain
that even if they couldn't maintain the
Batman license these people are
excellent at making these type of games
just go to Marvel and least one of them
people would be exclusive I can get okay
I think tickler game would be exclusive
because Microsoft is being very petty
right now and they is they do thanks man
what else we got so but yet you got a $5
tip jar from Rob mayhem not yeah okay
look we'll keep Mortal Kombat and kill
dancing and soda can keep can keep
street fighter and take Tekken back no
no no no I fought very hard to get
Tekken is still on Xbox that in socal oh
shut up the Soul Calibur the medic
finalists we said if Microsoft picks up
the WB studios big if the IP licenses
aren't necessary Rocksteady monolith W
Montreal have a chance to build new IP
which is true finally it won't be held
down by having to make these IP but
these IP so Victor Alice Dean I know you
miss I miss Mariano pump out the $2
super chat take the minis come that's
right yeah we got it we got a bet Milla
Marcus we in the mix yeah yeah you got
jumped big-time then we have squirrely
down with the $2 super chat can't give
knees when you win you a snake my god
depending Microsoft would also would
need a warmer other studio size purchase
of Japanese developers that would could
be done I definitely need a Japanese
developer and when we can when we say
there they might be buying these it's a
huge it's a lot of money we got a super
chef from Victor Alice tea this is a
rare opportunity that a company like
Tinson Mike Fox decides not to rock
better than all the x-box studio or it
out to Jes Gordon because he said it he
was like dude just just to block them
from buying everything you have to get
it instant buys them everybody sideshow
doctors this is his stock market in
analysis and gotta be so epic you see
just people just very quiet on Twitter
you got the medic we got uh you had uh
squirrely damn we got squirrely Dan kaga
is gonna collect that's why I need
Microsoft to get WB a Japanese dev and a
so Bo yes I'm with them be with the
following Chet uses five dollars for the
shipping label for LaMarcus due to play
stage about like don't let me or don't
let their horizon West news come follow
my feet just means we have the president
this is this is an example so
non-acceptance this is this why I got a
new dingus I'm not arguing with you on
Twitter
put your knees up in here we go what's
comedy because y'all keep acting like
this not this is to do reality I can't
wait
and this is not about me what no
all this to happen this is just where
it's going just come out miles is baby I
lose I lose I put it up there you know
me Kayla would be lazy in the market is
going down with the ship
she lose on PlayStation you renew regard
a wall gonna be played bet you know this
news came across you know this is this
is crazy and I'm saying what the WB geez
super mega like we don't like I forgot
the bread to do all this stuff but to me
just the reality of of it happening and
I want you to think about it this way
right because this is the same
conversation that I was hearing when it
was Disney trying to acquire Fox right
and it was a lot of hurdles and stuff
that dudes head right at one time I went
through then it didn't go through
he was left was right but that do it by
a process of elimination
um rock star know right because Roger
would I wouldn't be more concerned with
Activision yeah right EA would want but
Activision can acquire right but it's
about and I always say it's always about
those two individuals if they can
convince the parent come because
remember I don't know how big sake is
bag is right but I think that those
those type of things those moves who
requires convincing higher-ups do I
believe that Phil wants it yeah do I
believe that he can have a Satya
understand the ramifications on what
will happen if they acquire yes is it
three tip can they convince the uppers
right this deal is going to be as mega
as Fox and Disney oh I'm not saying that
it can't happen I'm just saying the
reason why I don't feel it will
I feel w be trying to drive the price up
so my thing is they like yo Microsoft
interested in is tool so what you gonna
do like to me that or list this this
elite like next yeah I feel like this
week not like every time the bronzer
free agent and then it makes me like
Yoda dicks for interest just like like
the part about it that I like is that
Phyllis Shula shop and you like that
aggressiveness under the leadership is
when it's not Don Mattrick and I'm
saying I like I wind up going for it
I still think WB just try to draw out a
price little bit and keep in mind that
you know there's a slim chance that
Microsoft doesn't buy this but a buy no
matter what Saudi dudes gonna do and I'm
good I do I'm gonna be so extra yeah
there's two scenarios in life never
never gonna do that and that the thirst
if it happens then they're gonna be like
it doesn't matter they're gonna get
there are two scenarios in life where
I'm extra like extra extra like so extra
you guys can you know one of them is
that Microsoft absolutely blows it out
of the park on the July the 23rd and the
second one is that they by Warner
Brothers not they happen on the same day
I love this yeah I talk yeah I'm just
telling no like I've been around when
all Microsoft go buy a back a sauce go
pasta dough I don't really think it was
an open bid it was just like blame
rumors like not a letter of attempt like
you know absolutely that that part is
different I give y'all the letter to
attend okay yes that's real I respect
the move I just gotta see it man like
there's a lot of dudes trying to try to
get this sell-off so we'll see I hope
they
I'll be happy I'll be happy to be wrong
a billion if you imagine how disgusting
it will smell if ei gets a hole in him
like really what what happened yeah
might as well just pack it up like this
forget about how that quality in a
Batman gonna be forget about who you
used to know perfect I'm jumping one but
I'll go back together restore the Hades
a 2004 chat let's be honest Microsoft is
the lesser evil yes absolutely because
we all scared to death if we go to
Activision we scared it down for EA
Bungie did ya see below that's that's
what I got shady game with the final
sweet n think about all the times
Microsoft didn't buy a team that they
were Bioware splash damage cloud giant
cow gene iron galaxy they need to get WB
to stop others yep as special they lost
iron galaxy to watch McCullough to
Amazon and those are the people that
were working on killing anything so you
see how a stagnated killing instinct got
the moment that they got acquired by
another company they can't allow that to
continue they can't let ip's it just
bring back just die like that
I just personally feel like it would it
would be different if I didn't think
that I always think this is literally
the perfect thing like Microsoft this is
one of those opportunities especially
they can get like the Batman licensing
yeah I mean or is it extremely and I
personally I feel like Batman's ran its
course I would prefer them to let that
license and go and like get like black
black panther or something because I
feel like we need a different hero than
the one that's been used for like 15 20
years but Batman is extremely popular so
even if they got it that was movie
coming out bro no you need Batman like
it was none of those things we got
perfect showing the two dollars will be
said drop the bag Satya well what is God
doing [ __ ] is in there fighting with
somebody even again
we can't hear you with yeah we can't
hear anything that you're saying I love
bad my bad done no cursing out no he
said God we're happening that's a
supposed to take the higher ground he
covered attitude put Jim you're not
supposed to participate in smoke you're
supposed to to mate eight reason right
you right I've got be a professional be
honestly know that you're Manning your
convictions like your boy weird to
tattoo on his chest
hey I'm a bit about conviction I'll do
the spicy took I want these I want back
sigh what you got a knife for the line I
want to make an example let's get it we
got to super chest we caught up yeah all
right um new our peephole with Phil
Spencer's latest statements are going to
series X being held back by older Xbox
platforms as a meme created by people
who are too caught up in device
competition do you agree that games
should not be locked in to having to buy
a new device in order to experience it
the choices are a no film is tripping
tripping games I will always be held
back by the lowest common denominator B
yes the majority of games scale for PC
already and still have the highest
graphical fidelity or C I don't care
both series X and place there's your
father damage control and they
limitations to PC master-race
those are the choices please Rock the
Vote when it goes up on Twitter salute
alors Giuseppina Varia one of the best
coders in the game
splash damages all came through show
love a lot of retro talk man
he was really phenomenal salute to him
we'll definitely try to get him back as
things get closer hopefully with Splash
Damage next project or what gives a
tactics comes out on our series X so
salute they have an overlap but on yeah
man we got the super Chester then you do
your intros on you want to get those
real quick Soph before Albert Mariano
pom pom with the $2 super check I'm all
for ggressive car and then we have we
have black wood black Ronan back to roll
in which is flat also which have Black
Panthers a third-person action-adventure
game wouldn't be life-giving yeah will
be hi I'm guest Smith with the powers if
LaMarcus doesn't have everything how is
he going to get more what you smoke but
I guess I Amazon I guess leader holy
Lord Lord addict wicked a firefighter
these fries no pizza no look man it's
four o'clock it's my it's it's
dinnertime
yeah yeah that's a fact as a fan no
doubt you already know Lord sovereign or
just going over every spice he ever talk
man we're gonna [ __ ] find you what you
got going on shell Amanda's just tell me
this week you know I gotta go to work a
little bit but uh I'm actually yeah I
did Friday man I've heard a lot of good
things about sushi mother that you know
had me worried early
so I'd quest like which right now I
heard that is a good choice Cherry
Blossom time baby
I'm a little more excited than I had
been so I'm excited for that on Friday
people marry it well on Friday season
women shared also get that paper oh by
the way um next week I'm gonna be
dropping a few videos on halo and fables
so definitely if you ain't subscribe to
me on gaming attic you might want to go
over there and do that no Lord King
fresh off that IOP crisper aisle people
like what impressed in the chapter came
Cressida Jeff
the
in a video while I was in the on the
show today that video has to go up I was
trying to get that out for you guys
yesterday but only realm members like if
y'all heard what I put up y'all
understand its it sounds a little bit
like this we can't get monetized for
this because this is this is mine so
it's out so it sounds like hold on let
me get that for you kisses it's not that
I'm so proud of myself with how I made
it sound because it's mad is cheeky
listen guys I was like he sounds like
that
that better call all from Breaking Bad
yes I felt so happy and gleeful when I
said like you won't see it unless you're
a member of the room and all you members
that are in the realm I do salute you
guys so all you guys gave me strength
when I was laying it on the table and
getting tattooed for seven hours you
know um
attic attic was ride with me the whole
time he's he's like damn you still live
taking pictures I'm doing whatever it
was a real isolated situation because I
wasn't able to bring anyone with me so
you know for you for still able to get
yeah he was he listen um shout out to
our Pony Montana
yeah his joint is his Twitter his
Instagram is P o NY t82 number to follow
him on Instagram Pony - yeah you tattoo
oh that's funny the fanboy a reference
to the Basel he watches the show and
that's insane because I sent him the
link he looked at the show and he's a
fan of the show and he says you know
salute to you guy so we'll be working
exclusively that you will not see the
nipple unless you pay for that so we
won't talk about only fans will say yeah
he said wait a video okay he still he
just did the tattoo said he was in there
for seven eight hours man had to get his
rest on he didn't he gonna put up the
pole he doing the editing of the video
so - yesterday yeah eight hours y'all
you don't say so give him that now you
figure worst-case scenario tomorrow
maybe you'd be ready yeah well it'll
definitely be up tomorrow um I have a
box coming in from sideshow tomorrow so
I'll be doing that video Wednesday I
have two shows to do so Monday we'll be
doing a lot of a super super deep dive
very intricate stuff and onto they will
be doing an unboxing for the winner of
the $800 they got to statue from Dolph
channel Dolph Castle X I told you guys
listen y'all can go yeah they give it
away a lot of stuff once a month and one
of the winners got $800 in spec fortune
money and they already got they they dig
the statute yeah got one request King
yes one request is very important
question Thank You rid of that Mario
next week man no max creepy so next week
it's gonna be right the but you know
like every weekend gets you what's nuts
is I don't see W sure Mario's removed
this is all you gonna cakes awfully you
know it'll be up so bad
y'all salute I get everybody can't do
the check everybody again I get some
loot LaMarcus you know it's all funny
games brother we just had fun all that
good stuff man tune into next week as we
get closer we gonna have some more fun
stuff going on any battery
I was giving a little preview of that Oh
exclusive only freeze nipple so
collarbone get a little callable
collarbone action the res get the
residues is anyway I guess it's thanks
for stopping with us cuz we had to be
sawed off going on at the same time
everybody enjoy your Sunday no oh what I
got I gotta send you something oh yeah
yeah no you I'm Lord King David of iron
Lords podcast and we're bringing to you
an exciting new giveaway this giveaway
is like none other
we'll be giving away an Xbox Series X
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're able to be part of that giveaway
there's two ways to get your name thrown
in the head for the raffle one become a
member of the realm that's hit that joy
button hit hit that joy button you hit
that joint button down at the bottom and
you can become a member and also another
way is by becoming a patreon member so
you can be part of the realm as well now
this is brought to you by cat daddy fat
stacks a member and lord of the realm a
very generous person that's in our
community and this community is
beautiful so remember you can have one
entry by hitting that join button and
becoming a member of the realm and also
you can have another entry by being a
patreon now
you said King what if I'm a member of
both well your name gets thrown in the
Hat two times so please
like follow us subscribe join or become
a patreon member or become both and your
name is in the Hat to get that Xbox
series X as to who did their for you
sweepstakes this is wonderful this is
something that I'm sure that you will
enjoy oh man